This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you've been listening to our Power Broker breakdown series, you know my co-host, Elliot Cailin. Elliot is an unbelievably productive person who juggles way more projects than I could possibly keep track of. But I first got to know Elliot over a decade ago as one of the co-hosts of one of my first favorite podcasts called The Flophouse. It's from our friends at Maximum Fun and it's all about movies, specifically
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯。如果你一直在收听我们的《权力掮客》深度解析系列，那你一定认识我的联合主持人埃利奥特·卡林。埃利奥特是一个极其高效的人，他同时处理的项目多到我根本数不过来。但我第一次认识埃利奥特是在十多年前，当时他是我的首批挚爱播客之一《The Flophouse》的联合主持人。该节目来自我们的朋友Maximum Fun，内容全是关于电影的，具体来说是
bad movies, box office bombs, critical duds, and movies that should not have ever been made in the first place. As fate would have it, there is one movie in 2024 that lands at that exact Venn diagram of The Flophouse and the Power Broker, and that is Francis Ford Coppola's Megalopolis. It is a difficult movie to summarize, as you will hear, but essentially Adam Driver plays a city planner that's very, very, very loosely based on Robert Moses. This time you've gone too far, Catalina.
烂片、票房毒药、影评灾难，以及那些根本就不该被拍出来的电影。巧合的是，2024年有一部电影正好处于《The Flophouse》和《权力掮客》的交集点，那就是弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉的《大都会》。正如你即将听到的，这部电影很难概括，但基本上亚当·德赖弗饰演了一位城市规划师，其原型非常、非常、非常松散地取材于罗伯特·摩西。这次你做得太过分了，卡塔琳娜。
This site is under design authority jurisdiction. What happens if you've overstepped your mandate? We'll apologize. Apologize? After the building's down, Mayor Cicero will be pissed. And it is a bad movie. And you think one year of medical school entitles you to plow through the riches of my Amazonian mind?
这个场地受设计管理局管辖。如果你越权了会怎样？我们会道歉。道歉？大楼倒塌后，西塞罗市长会气疯的。而且这是一部烂片。你以为读了一年医学院就有权践踏我那亚马逊式思维的财富了吗？
Entitles me? Yes. Entitles me? Yes. Entitles me? Yes. Entitles me? Yes. Entitles me? Yes. A few weeks back, I went on the Flophouse to talk about Megalopolis, not just as a movie,
我有权吗？是的。我有权吗？是的。我有权吗？是的。我有权吗？是的。我有权吗？是的。几周前，我上了《The Flophouse》节目去谈论《大都会》，不仅仅是作为一部电影，
but as a vision of an urban utopia. Is this society, is this way we're living the only one that's available to us? And when we ask these questions, when there's a dialogue about them, that basically is a utopia. Not that it's a very clear vision, but you know, you'll see. Enjoy.
而是作为一种城市乌托邦的愿景。这就是社会吗？这就是我们唯一能拥有的生活方式吗？当我们提出这些问题，当围绕这些问题展开对话时，那基本上就是一种乌托邦。虽然这并不是一个非常清晰的愿景，但你知道的，你会明白的。享受吧。
On this episode we discuss Megalopolis. I got a feeling this is going to be a mega love fest. That's a good one. Yum yum. Delish. Hey everyone, welcome to the Flophouse. I'm Dan McCoy. I'm Stuart Wellington. I'm Elliott Kalin. And I'm Roman Mars.
在本期节目中，我们讨论《大都会》。我有种预感，这会是一场盛大的爱之庆典。说得好。美味，美味。嘿，大家好，欢迎来到《The Flophouse》。我是丹·麦考伊。我是斯图尔特·惠灵顿。我是埃利奥特·卡林。我是罗曼·马斯。
Wait, what? Hold on a second. What? How did you get here? How did you get here? Dan, I told you, you got to have your apartment fumigated. You got to get a Roman Mars infestation. Someone much more respectable got in here somehow.
等等，什么？等一下。什么？你是怎么到这儿来的？你是怎么到这儿来的？丹，我告诉过你，你得给公寓做熏蒸。你得处理一下“罗曼·马斯”入侵的问题。不知怎么的，一个更体面的人混进来了。
I got on my lit up moving sidewalk and I landed right here. Wow, in the city of the future, aka the Flau Paz. Yeah, well, we, you know, this is a special movie, a very special movie, so we had to have a very special guest. Elliott, why don't you talk a little bit about Roman being on the show? Because you have been doing some work with, you've been moonlighting, you've been cheating on us with another podcast. That's right. It's been so exciting to be discovering new things with another host, discovering things about myself, showing them things about me
我坐上我那发光的自动人行道，然后就降落在这里了。哇，在未来之城，也就是《The Flophouse》。是啊，嗯，你知道，这是一部特别的电影，一部非常特别的电影，所以我们必须请一位非常特别的嘉宾。埃利奥特，你为什么不谈谈罗曼上节目的事呢？因为你一直在做一些工作，你在兼职，你在用另一个播客背叛我们。没错。能和另一位主持人一起发现新事物，发现关于我自己的事，向他们展示关于我的事，真是太令人兴奋了，
that you guys have gotten bored with. It's made you a better co-host of the Flophouse, honestly. In some ways, yeah, because I'm more excited. I come in and I kiss you guys and I give you flowers and you're like, what's this? You haven't done this in years. And I've got a spring in my step and a song in my heart. So Megalopolis is a special movie in that it feels like it is so indebted to the ideas of city building that come from having read the Power Broker and then forgotten most of what was in the book.
你们已经对这些感到厌倦了。老实说，这让你成为了《The Flophouse》更好的联合主持人。在某些方面，是的，因为我更兴奋了。我进来亲吻你们，给你们送花，你们却说，这是什么？你已经好几年没这么做了。我脚步轻快，心中充满歌声。《大都会》是一部特别的电影，因为它似乎非常得益于那种城市建设的理念，这些理念源于阅读了《权力掮客》然后又忘记了书中大部分内容。
And so what better person have come talk to us than Roman Mars with whom I have been co-hosting the 99% invisible breakdown the Power Broker all throughout this year. We have been taking on one of the greatest works of nonfiction writing or I would say writing period in American literature, The Power Broker by Robert Caro. Every month we break down a hundred pages of it. We just recorded our penultimate summary episode. We actually made our way through most of the book at this point.
所以，还有谁比罗曼·马斯更适合来和我们谈谈呢？今年一整年，我一直和他共同主持《99% Invisible》对《权力掮客》的深度解析。我们一直在挑战美国文学中最伟大的非虚构作品，或者我应该说是最伟大的作品之一，罗伯特·卡罗的《权力掮客》。每个月我们都会解析其中的一百页。我们刚刚录制了倒数第二期的总结节目。实际上，到目前为止，我们已经读完了这本书的大部分内容。
And so, The Power Broker is always on our minds. And this movie, Megalopolis, there's so much about it that is so clearly indebted to a certain idea of Robert Moses, the subject of the power broker and indebted in a way that is totally weird and doesn't really work and is messed up. And so we wanted to bring Roman on to talk about that aspect of it and also have a little bit of synergistic cross promotion between these two endeavors. But... I thought because we're talking about a movie that's all about New Rome, we would bring
所以，《权力掮客》一直萦绕在我们的脑海中。而这部电影《大都会》，其中有太多内容显然得益于罗伯特·摩西的某种理念——也就是《权力掮客》的主角——这种得益方式非常怪异，并不真正奏效，而且一团糟。所以我们想请罗曼来谈谈这方面，同时也在这两个努力之间进行一点协同的交叉推广。但是……我想因为我们谈论的是一部关于“新罗马”的电影，我们会带
in the best Roman we know. Name-based pun scenario. An actual Roman. Yeah. Yeah, that's right. That's right. No, I'm very happy to be here. Thank you so much for having me.
来我们认识的最好的“罗马人”。基于名字的双关语场景。一个真正的罗马人。是的。是的，没错。不，我很高兴能来到这里。非常感谢你们邀请我。
And I don't think if I kind of needed a sort of a work excuse to see this movie because it looked a little bit, I don't know, like something I wouldn't necessarily see on my own. And so it was a good excuse. You would make this, as I did, the only movie I've seen in the theater for the past couple of months. That's amazing. As soon as we decided that I would see it for the show, I was very excited to take it in.
而且我不认为我需要一个工作借口来看这部电影，因为它看起来有点，我不知道，像是我自己不一定会去看的东西。所以这是一个很好的借口。你会像我一样，把它当作我过去几个月里在电影院看过的唯一一部电影。这太棒了。当我们决定为了节目去看它时，我非常兴奋能去欣赏它。
But anyway, we'll get to that. No, I mean, I'm on the show all the time and I had a similar experience where I'm like, well, I mean, maybe it's partly because I'm like, well, we'll probably have to watch that eventually. So I don't need to run out to the theater to do it. But then when we all decided to do this together, I'm like, oh, great, I can see it on a big screen I can see all the the nutty vision of Francis Ford Coppola all of the ideas that he's been saving up for decades and put them
但不管怎样，我们稍后再谈。不，我的意思是，我经常上这个节目，我有过类似的经历，我想，好吧，我的意思是，也许部分原因是我觉得，嗯，我们可能最终得看那部电影。所以我不需要急着去电影院看。但当我们决定一起做这件事时，我想，哦，太棒了，我可以在大银幕上看到它，我可以看到弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉所有疯狂的愿景，他几十年来一直积攒的所有想法，并把它们
All in one script whether they all belong in the same script or not. Yeah What's the last one we did in last flop house in the aisles we did? I think like sister says the one with process Professor Crowe? Was Madame Webb since then? Oh, Madame Webb was... Oh, no, you know what? I saw it in the theaters when we saw it. That was the theater movie. Guys, can we talk about Madame Webb? You know, her web connects us all.
全部放在一个剧本里，不管它们是否都属于同一个剧本。是的。我们在上一次《The Flophouse》里做的是哪一部？我想是《蜘蛛夫人》？那是教授克罗的那部吗？那是《蜘蛛夫人》之后吗？哦，不，你知道吗？我们看的时候是在电影院看的。那是电影院电影。伙计们，我们能谈谈《蜘蛛夫人》吗？你知道，她的网连接着我们所有人。
Kind of like how Megalon connects all these houses. Yeah, sure. So, the other thing about this movie is that I wanted to see it in the theaters because unlike every other movie we've seen, where there's a reasonable expectation it will be available for home viewing and like, they're like, gotta see this new Marvel or Star Wars movie or whatever in the theaters. I'm like, I don't have to because I'll be able to see it on my nicely sized DCV at home. This movie, conceivably, could disappear.
有点像《大都会》连接着所有这些房子。是的，当然。所以，关于这部电影的另一件事是，我想在电影院看它，因为不像我们看过的其他每一部电影，人们有合理的预期它会在家庭影院上映，比如，他们会说，必须在电影院看这部新的漫威或星球大战电影之类的。我却觉得，我不必去，因为我可以在家里那台尺寸不错的电视上看到它。这部电影，可以想象，可能会消失。
It is a Francis Ford Coppola owned thing. It's amazing to me that it was a national release movie and it's very possible that it may disappear after this. I don't think it will. I think it will be home viewing somewhere, but this is such an indie film in so many ways that it's potentially unavailable at a certain point. So we had to see it when we could see it.
这是弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉拥有的东西。令我惊讶的是，它是一部全国发行的电影，而且很有可能在这次之后就消失了。我不认为会这样。我认为它会在某个地方进行家庭放映，但这在很多方面都是一部如此独立的电影，以至于它在某个时间点可能会无法观看。所以我们必须在能看的时候去看。
I guess I see what you're saying in the sense that the response to this was so, I mean there are people who are like, wow, big swing, love you Francis, but for the most part, very negative that there could be a part of them that's like, well I'm taking my ball and going back to my vineyard. But like, if he doesn't have a vineyard anymore.
我想我明白你的意思了，因为对此的反应是如此……我的意思是，有些人会说，哇，大手笔，爱你弗朗西斯，但大部分人是非常负面的，以至于他们可能会觉得，好吧，我带着我的球回我的葡萄园去了。但是，如果他不再拥有葡萄园了呢。
Oh yeah. I know he only sold part of it, he only sold part of the vineyard. But if he doesn't have a vineyard anymore. Oh yeah, shit. There's this movie. He only sold part of it. He only sold part of the vineyard. But if he wants to recoup anything, like it has to go to streaming. It has to be available somewhere. It's more that, so it was distributed theatrically by Lionsgate, but it's more like,
哦，是的。我知道他只卖了一部分，他只卖了葡萄园的一部分。但如果他不再拥有葡萄园了呢。哦，是的，该死。还有这部电影。他只卖了一部分。他只卖了葡萄园的一部分。但如果他想收回任何成本，它就必须流媒体化。它必须在某个地方可以观看。更多的是，它是由狮门影业在院线发行的，但更像是，
I can see a world where a large distributor is like, we don't want to handle this. And so he has to scramble to find some way. And maybe it's up on, maybe it's for instance, for a couple of YouTube channel that he uploads all of Megalopolis to in 10 chapters or something like that. But yeah, his TikTok channel, he just splits it all up.
我可以想象一个大型发行商会说，我们不想处理这个。所以他必须想方设法。也许是在，也许是弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉的YouTube频道，他把《大都会》分成了10章上传之类的。但是的，他的TikTok频道，他只是把它全部分割开了。
You know, in a way didn't didn't Lionsgate also distribute Borderlands this year. Man, they're having a tough one. It's been a great year for Lionsgate, but in a world where even movies that are owned by corporations are not readily available the way that they maybe once were or that we assume they are. To have a movie that is one, literally one guy paid for it himself.
你知道，某种程度上，狮门影业今年不是也发行了《无主之地》吗？天哪，他们过得很艰难。对狮门影业来说这是伟大的一年，但在一个即使是公司拥有的电影也不像过去那样容易获得，或者不像我们假设的那样容易获得的世界里。拥有一部电影，一是字面意义上是一个人自己掏钱拍的。
It is, anyway, I guess all along I was saying like I had to see it in the theater because it was the first time in years that a movie has come out where I'd be like, this might be my only chance to see this movie. And of course, maybe it'll be on HBO Max next week. I don't know. But I was like, this could be my only shot, you know. Yeah. There was only one theater showing it when I was looking for it. Well, it was, there was maybe a couple, but it was like showing at 3 p.m.
总之，我想我一直说我必须在电影院看它，因为这是多年来第一次有一部电影上映，我会觉得，这可能是我看这部电影的唯一机会。当然，也许下周它就会在HBO Max上播出了。我不知道。但我当时想，这可能是我唯一的机会，你知道。是的。我找的时候只有一家电影院在放映。好吧，也许有几家，但它是在下午3点放映。
or something at Emery Bay. Makes sense with the Bay Area. Tech companies hate this guy. It's a couple of countries. That's couple of countries. That's the Bay Area. His offices were in San Francisco. He lives up over in the Napa area. And then we ended up seeing it at the Kabuki, my wife and I saw the Kabuki Theater in Japantown in San Francisco, which was, we went to dinner ahead of time.
或者在埃默里湾之类的。在湾区很有道理。科技公司讨厌这家伙。这是几个国家。那是几个国家。那是湾区。他的办公室在旧金山。他住在纳帕地区。然后我们最终在歌舞伎剧院看了它，我和我妻子在旧金山日本城的歌舞伎剧院看的，我们提前去吃了晚饭。
Pretty on the nose name for a theater in Japantown. But it was a weird experience, That was a weird vibe. I want to ask, how does your wife feel about our podcast now? You host this. There was about midway through the movie where she looked at me and she said, why is Francis Ford Coppola doing this to us? But it started from the very beginning. We sat down in empty theater. It didn't stay empty, but it started empty.
对于日本城的一家剧院来说，这个名字真是太贴切了。但这是一种奇怪的体验，那是一种奇怪的氛围。我想问，你妻子现在对我们的播客感觉如何？你主持这个节目。电影进行到一半时，她看着我说，为什么弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉要这样对我们？但从一开始就是这样。我们坐在空荡荡的剧院里。它没有一直空着，但开始时是空的。
We were there early. Like, just, you know, we just got there after dinner and the place is completely empty. And then this older white woman comes and sits right next to my wife. Like the theater is empty. There's two of us. Your wife is a very friendly person. There's something very welcoming about her. So I get it.
我们去得很早。就像，你知道，我们吃完晚饭就到了，那个地方完全是空的。然后这个年长的白人妇女走过来，坐在我妻子旁边。剧院是空的。我们有两个人。你妻子是一个非常友好的人。她身上有一种非常受欢迎的气质。所以我明白了。
Yeah. I was like, and it already started. It was like, oh, this is, there's a weird vibe here that you would want to sit right next to us in this little pack. And then it just kept on getting weird because more and more people sat like glommed on right around us. Maybe they just wanted to sort of like sit mostly in the middle because it's a spectacle and whatever.
是的。我当时想，而且电影已经开始了。就像，哦，这，这里有一种奇怪的氛围，你会想直接坐在我们旁边这个小包围圈里。然后它就一直变得很奇怪，因为越来越多的人像粘在我们周围一样坐了下来。也许他们只是想坐在中间，因为这是一种奇观之类的。
But, but it started out weird. It just got weirder. Yeah. Well, well, speaking of how weird it gets, Stuart, you took notes, we all saw this, as we said, in the theater, because that's the way we could do it. I respect you for- I took the notes in the dark of the Alamo.
但是，但是开始时很奇怪。它只是变得越来越奇怪。是的。嗯，说到它变得有多奇怪，斯图尔特，你做了笔记，我们都看了这个，正如我们所说，在电影院，因为那是我们能做到的方式。我尊重你——我在阿拉莫的黑暗中做了笔记。
Yeah, being able to do that. Well, I mean, we're going to see how good these notes are, since I transcribed them onto note cards, and I'm like, what the fuck does this say? To be fair, to be fair, this is- Surely you couldn't say that about Claudio. This is an intricate puzzle box of a movie. Every link indelibly forged to the next
是的，能做到这一点。好吧，我的意思是，我们要看看这些笔记有多好，因为我把它们转录到笔记卡上，然后我想，这到底写的是什么鬼？公平地说，公平地说，这是——你肯定不能那样说克劳迪奥。这是一个错综复杂的电影拼图盒。每一个环节都不可磨灭地锻造到下一个，
so that it just like, it's airtight. The thing about the movie is airtight. So I'm going to need some help here, guys. So, Megalopolis, movie opens with what? But like a title card, right? That's Megalopolis, a fable. Yeah, and right off the bat is like, hey, modern society is kind of like Rome,
所以它就像，它是密不透风的。这部电影的特点是密不透风。所以我需要一些帮助，伙计们。所以，《大都会》，电影以什么开头？就像一张标题卡，对吧？那是《大都会》，一个寓言。是的，而且一开始就是，嘿，现代社会有点像罗马，
if you think about it. It's true. I mean, it is a movie that is, it is a movie that, one,, anytime a filmmaker puts a fable at the end of their title, you go, this movie is not going to make sense. This is, this is a, this is a, that's calling it a fable really. It's like when we did North a while back, I was thinking about these, these interviews I've heard with Alan Zweibel, who wrote North, and he just kept saying, it's a fable, like
如果你仔细想想的话。这是真的。我的意思是，这是一部电影，它是，它是一部电影，第一，任何电影制作人在他们的标题末尾加上一个寓言，你就会想，这部电影不会有意义的。这是一个，这是一个，这是一个，称它为寓言真的。这就像我们很久以前做《北》的时候，我一直在想这些我听过的关于艾伦·茨威贝尔的采访，他写了《北》，他一直说，这是一个寓言，就像
it's a fairy tale. Why do people dislike it? It's like, you can't just, you can't bandage over a movie that doesn't make sense by calling it a fable. It is the equivalent of being like, I washed my hands of this at the beginning of the movie. It's like when a political candidate says something racist and they're like, it was a joke, come on everybody. Like, well, if people liked it,
它是一个童话故事。为什么人们不喜欢它？就像，你不能仅仅通过称它为寓言来掩盖一部没有意义的电影。这相当于说，我在电影开始时就洗手不干了。这就像当一个政治候选人说了种族主义的话，然后他们说，这只是个玩笑，大家别当真。就像，好吧，如果人们喜欢它，
you wouldn't say it was a joke. But anyway, that never happens, so don't worry about it. But you're right, Stuart, at the very beginning, they start with their thesis statement. Hey, America's kind of like Rome. Is America gonna fall like Rome does? And we have title cards that look like they're chiseled into marble.
你不会说这是一个玩笑。但不管怎样，这种情况从未发生过，所以别担心。但你是对的，斯图尔特，在最开始，他们以他们的论点陈述开始。嘿，美国有点像罗马。美国会像罗马那样衰落吗？我们有看起来像是凿在大理石上的标题卡。
So you're like, oh, that's like classic Roman shit. Okay, so let's just talk about some of the characters and then we'll get into the plot. I think that's easy. So our hero are- Easier than trying to walk us through the actual sequence, which is baffling. Let's talk about some of the characters and then we'll get into the plot. I think that's easy. So our hero are... Yeah, easier than trying to walk us through the actual sequence, which is baffling. Our protagonist is Caesar Catalina, played by Adam Driver.
所以你会想，哦，那是经典的罗马玩意儿。好吧，让我们谈谈一些角色，然后我们进入情节。我认为这很容易。所以我们的英雄是——比试图带我们走过实际的序列要容易，这令人困惑。让我们谈谈一些角色，然后我们进入情节。我认为这很容易。所以我们的英雄是……是的，比试图带我们走过实际的序列要容易，这令人困惑。我们的主角是凯撒·卡塔琳娜，由亚当·德赖弗饰演。
It's impossible to say this name and not smile. I mean, come on. Yeah, because you're eating in a Catalina Island. Uh-huh, and it's a Caesar salad. I love it. The ultimate fantasy of eating a Caesar salad on Catalina Island. Or with Catalina dressing on it. Oh yeah.
说出这个名字而不微笑是不可能的。我的意思是，得了吧。是的，因为你在吃卡塔琳娜岛。嗯哼，这是一个凯撒沙拉。我喜欢它。在卡塔琳娜岛上吃凯撒沙拉的终极幻想。或者上面加了卡塔琳娜调料。哦，是的。
Stop it. Stop it. Nice. Turn the cameras off. It's two types of salads in one. So he is the head... They prophesied a sandwich like this, the Ultra Salad. He is the genius head of the design authority of New Rome whose task is to design things like buildings and plan out the city, right? City planning type stuff.
停下。停下。不错。关掉摄像机。这是两种沙拉合二为一。所以他是负责人……他们预言了这样的三明治，超级沙拉。他是新罗马设计管理局的天才负责人，他的任务是设计建筑物和规划城市之类的东西，对吧？城市规划之类的事情。
He is the master builder of New Rome. He is also the inventor or discoverer of Megalon, a magic super substance. Yes. The metal of the future, yeah. He also has the ability to stop time. Oh yes. And I do not object to this film
他是新罗马的建筑大师。他也是“美加隆”的发明者或发现者，一种神奇的超级物质。是的。未来的金属，是的。他还有停止时间的能力。哦，是的。我不反对这部电影
having a magical realist component. I don't even particularly object to it not being explained why he can do this, because what explanation would be appropriate? Would be necessary. I mean, it's I would, I met the problem with him. Oh, yeah, I'll leave it as yet. But this is a very large, bizarre elements to be added to the film with no appearance like, I mean, I wouldn't say no apparent, but like, it seems like it should have more thematic heft
有一个魔幻现实主义的成分。我甚至不特别反对它没有解释为什么他能做到这一点，因为什么样的解释才是合适的？才是必要的。我的意思是，我，我遇到了他的问题。哦，是的，我先留着它。但这在电影中是一个非常大、非常离奇的元素，没有出现，就像，我的意思是，我不会说没有出现，但就像，如果要在里面放这个东西，它似乎应该有更多的专题分量
or something if you're going to put this thing in there? I mean, I might be just too dumb to realize what's going on. I think you're right that it does not work on a plot level. I mean, I would say that when you say magical realist, the issue is that there is no realist aspect to this. It's just all magic. And Adam Driver's character is so clearly a stand-in for the artist and in this case, the filmmaker. And I think his ability to stop time is supposed to be
或者其他什么？我的意思是，我可能太笨了，没意识到发生了什么。我认为你是对的，它在情节层面上不起作用。我的意思是，我会说当你说是魔幻现实主义时，问题在于这部电影中没有任何现实主义的方面。这全是魔法。亚当·德赖弗的角色非常明显是艺术家的替身，在这种情况下，是电影制作人的替身。我认为他停止时间的能力应该是
the artist's ability to reshape the world around them, even more explicitly than him just building buildings and stuff like that. But you're right, he doesn't do anything with it. Like he never uses it for anything. As a plot device, it is like an anti-Chekhov's gun. Like it never pays off in any meaningful way of how the story goes.
艺术家重塑周围世界的能力，甚至比他只是建造建筑物之类的东西更明确。但你是对的，他没有用它做任何事。作为一个情节装置，它就像一把反契诃夫之枪。它在故事的发展方式上从未以任何有意义的方式得到回报。
And especially when you're talking about someone who is struggling in a power play, you would think, why don't you use some of your time stopping powers to achieve your ends or something? Stop time and pull the mayor's pants down so he looks ridiculous when you start time again. If Megalopolis was released as a series of episodes, the nerds in the Megalopolis sub Reddit would be like, why isn't Caesar using his powers? They'd be like, I know, in the last episode, he's going to use his powers to do X, X, and Y. And then when the show doesn't do what they thought it was going to do, they'll be like,
特别是当你谈论一个在权力博弈中挣扎的人时，你会想，为什么你不利用你的一些时间停止能力来实现你的目的之类的？停止时间，把市长的裤子拉下来，这样当你再次开始时间时，他看起来就很可笑。如果《大都会》是作为一系列剧集发行的，那么《大都会》子版块里的书呆子们会说，为什么凯撒不使用他的能力？他们会说，我知道，在最后一集里，他会使用他的能力来做X、X和Y。然后当节目没有做他们认为会做的事情时，他们会说，
this show sucks. This show sucks. I think also, to me, an element of this time stop power is like it plays into the fantasy of a guy who is trying to achieve something amazing, but he is beset by all this other stuff, all this background noise, so many things like distracting him from what he's trying to do, and the fantasy of being able to just stop everything and focus on the one thing he wants to work on. Especially for a filmmaker like Coppola, I'm sure that that's part of it for him.
这个节目烂透了。这个节目烂透了。我也认为，对我来说，这种时间停止能力的一个元素就像是一个试图实现某种惊人目标的人的幻想，但他被所有其他东西、所有这些背景噪音所困扰，这么多事情分散了他试图做的事情的注意力，而能够停止一切并专注于他想做的一件事的幻想。特别是对于像科波拉这样的电影制作人，我相信这是他的一部分。
Well, it reminds me of the story I've heard about Stanley Kubrick and Jerry Lewis talking that they were both editing movies at the same facility and both took a break at the same time. And Jerry Lewis was like, well, you can't polish a turd. And Kubrick says, you can if you freeze it. And this idea that if you can just stop time, then you can, you can do the work that otherwise would be impossible. You know, if you could just freeze something in place, you know. Sorry, I got a leg cramp, so I'm dancing around my chair.
嗯，这让我想起了我听过的关于斯坦利·库布里克和杰瑞·刘易斯谈话的故事，他们都在同一个设施里剪辑电影，并且同时休息。杰瑞·刘易斯说，嗯，你不能给一坨屎抛光。库布里克说，如果你把它冻住，你就可以。这个想法是，如果你能停止时间，那么你就可以，你就可以做否则不可能完成的工作。你知道，如果你能把某样东西冻结在原地，你知道。抱歉，我腿抽筋了，所以我绕着椅子跳舞。
Okay, so that's Caesar Catalina. We know who he is. He's super cool. Now, the mayor of New Rome is in a bit of a pickle. That's Mayor Frank Cicero, played by Giancarlo Esposito, who plays it a little hammy. I feel like Adam Driver is pretty straight in this one. I mean, well. I don't know about that.
好吧，那就是凯撒·卡塔琳娜。我们知道他是谁。他超级酷。现在，新罗马的市长陷入了困境。那是弗兰克·西塞罗市长，由吉安卡洛·埃斯波西托饰演，他演得有点夸张。我觉得亚当·德赖弗在这部电影里表现得相当直率。我的意思是，嗯。我不知道。
I was taking, I mean, he's like, Driver is big, like you can't not be in this movie. I mean, like the one, I mean, there are some performances that aren't big and they suffer for it. I think that I admire. And the best performances in the movie are the biggest performances, I feel like. Well, here's what I'd say. There are very hammy performances in the movie are the biggest performances, I feel like. Well, here's what I'd say.
我当时在想，我的意思是，他就像，德赖弗很大，就像你不能不在这部电影里。我的意思是，就像那个，我的意思是，有些表演并不大，而且它们因此而受苦。我认为我钦佩。而且我觉得电影中最好的表演是最大的表演。好吧，这就是我要说的。电影中非常夸张的表演是最大的表演，我觉得。好吧，这就是我要说的。
There are very hammy performances in this movie that are fun to watch because what else are you gonna do in a movie called Megalopolis with all this stuff in it than chew the scenery? And then there's Adam Driver who magically seems to create a grounded and consistent character despite the movie around him being gibberish. Like, he's amazing. And then gibberish, like she's amazing.
这部电影里有一些非常夸张的表演，看起来很有趣，因为在一部叫《大都会》的电影里，有这么多东西，除了咀嚼风景还能做什么？然后是亚当·德赖弗，尽管他周围的电影是胡言乱语，但他神奇地似乎创造了一个扎实且一致的角色。就像，他很棒。然后是胡言乱语，就像她很棒。
And then there's, we'll get to her, but the female lead is sort of lost in this movie because she is giving a small performance and the movie is not helping her out. To Natalie Emmanuelle, who is the daughter. Is good in other things, but is sort of not served by the film at all. Did you see her in that John Woo killer remake
然后是，我们稍后会谈到她，但女主角在这部电影中有点迷失，因为她表现得很小，而电影并没有帮助她。娜塔莉·伊曼纽尔，她是女儿。在其他事情上很好，但根本没有被这部电影服务。你看到她在吴宇森的《杀手》翻拍版里了吗？
where she does the very realistic jump and then latch her legs around a guy's neck and spin around shooting every other dude in the room. It's amazing. It's a solid move. It's cool. I mean, if you're going to use a move. That's why people do it all the time.
在那里她做了非常逼真的跳跃，然后用双腿锁住一个人的脖子，旋转着射击房间里的每一个其他人。这太棒了。这是一个扎实的动作。很酷。我的意思是，如果你要使用一个动作。这就是为什么人们一直这样做。
That's why it's such a common move. Yeah. It's a great move, but you can only do it once. Now, Madden Driver is set up. It feels like it's set up at first. This is the movie I was expecting at least was it is a battle between the mayor and the designer over the future of this portion of the city. And they each have competing goals.
这就是为什么它是一个如此常见的动作。是的。这是一个伟大的动作，但你只能做一次。现在，亚当·德赖弗被设定好了。起初感觉像是设定好了。至少我期待的电影是市长和设计师之间关于城市这一部分未来的战斗。他们每个人都有相互竞争的目标。
And we're going to see the pros and cons of each and it quickly becomes even though Adam Driver is kind of a Robert Mostife character, it quickly becomes no, he's a genius and everyone needs to just like, SCF you and let him do whatever he wants to do. Yeah, and and this kind of comes to a head in the first scene where we're also introduced to the mayor's daughter, Julia Cicero, who seems to be a vapid club girl,
我们将看到每个人的利弊，它很快就变成了，尽管亚当·德赖弗是一个罗伯特·摩西式的角色，它很快就变成了不，他是一个天才，每个人都需要像，滚开，让他做他想做的任何事。是的，而且这在第一个场景中达到了高潮，我们也介绍了市长的女儿朱莉娅·西塞罗，她似乎是一个肤浅的俱乐部女孩，
but she, but it turns out that she's much more than that. If anything, because she is able to witness Caesar when he stops time, it stops for her as well, and she can see what's going on. She can witness the stopping of time, and it doesn't affect her, which seems to be an indicator, yeah, that she has the hidden artistic ability or at least intellectual skill that Caesar has. And then the last big faction, I guess, in this is Crassus,
但她，但事实证明她远不止于此。如果说有什么不同的话，因为她能够见证凯撒停止时间，它也为她停止了，她可以看到发生了什么。她可以见证时间的停止，它并没有影响她，这似乎是一个指标，是的，她拥有凯撒所拥有的隐藏的艺术能力或至少是智力技能。然后我想这里最后一个大派系是克拉苏，
who is the owner of the largest bank. He's a very rich old man played by John Voight, who, guys, I think he knew what he was doing here. He brings a lot of juice. Well, as we'll see, he does deliver the best line in the entire movie later towards the end of the film. Yeah, I mean, he's had a lot of practice, like both playing and being ritualed as a whole. And doddering. Yeah, it mean he's had a lot of practice playing, like both playing and being ritualed asshole.
他是最大银行的所有者。他是一个非常有钱的老人，由乔恩·沃伊特饰演，伙计们，我想他知道他在做什么。他带来了很多活力。好吧，正如我们将看到的，他确实在电影接近尾声时说出了整部电影中最好的一句台词。是的，我的意思是，他练习了很多，既扮演又被视为一个混蛋。而且老糊涂。是的，我的意思是，他练习了很多扮演，既扮演又被视为一个混蛋。
And so. And doddering. Yeah, it's his thing. Now there's, now we should mention also, there's a lot of little side minor characters that pop up around here. They're all played by, for the most part, but like Dustin Hoffman shows up, James Reemar shows up,
所以。而且老糊涂。是的，这是他的事。现在有，现在我们也应该提到，这里出现了很多小配角。他们大部分都是由，但像达斯汀·霍夫曼出现了，詹姆斯·瑞马尔出现了，
like D.B. Sweeney shows up, like it's all these well-known faces. D.B. Sweeney? From The Cut Again? I know. Jason Schwartzman has a very good scene later on where he plays drums. Yes. Talia Shire, family member of Frans Ford Coppola, shows up.
像D.B.斯威尼出现了，就像所有这些众所周知的面孔。D.B.斯威尼？来自《切口》？我知道。杰森·舒瓦兹曼后来有一个非常好的场景，他打鼓。是的。塔莉娅·夏尔，弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉的家庭成员，出现了。
But it's one of these movies where it feels like one of these movies that is overstuffed with people. And you have to imagine there is hours and hours of footage. We didn't even talk about Lawrence Fishburne who is the... Yeah, Lawrence Fishburne, who's the narrator slash chauffeur. Yeah. And we also haven't even touched on the other two important characters. We have the son of Crassus, Claudio, played by Shia LaBeouf. And, wow, Platinum, journalist extraordinaire, played by...
但这感觉像是那种挤满了人的电影之一。你必须想象有数小时的镜头。我们甚至没有谈论劳伦斯·菲什伯恩，他是……是的，劳伦斯·菲什伯恩，他是叙述者兼司机。是的。而且我们甚至没有触及另外两个重要的角色。我们有克拉苏的儿子克劳迪奥，由希亚·拉博夫饰演。还有，哇，普拉特纳姆，非凡的记者，由……
She's very clearly a take on Maria Bartiromo. Maria Bartiromo, the money bunny, because she calls herself the money honey in this, right? The other way around. Maria Bartiromo, now she's just a straightforward Trump Trump all the time person. Her whole thing was she was the CNBC kind of like lady reporter. And they used to call her whatever one, while Plattnum is in this, she's the other one of either the money bunny or the money honey and I don't remember which one is which. What's there's right in.
她显然是玛丽亚·巴蒂罗莫的翻版。玛丽亚·巴蒂罗莫，那个“金钱兔女郎”，因为她在电影里自称“金钱甜心”，对吧？反过来了。玛丽亚·巴蒂罗莫，现在她只是一个直截了当的特朗普特朗普一直的人。她的全部事情是她是CNBC那种女士记者。他们过去叫她无论哪一个，而普拉特纳姆在这部电影里，她是“金钱兔女郎”或“金钱甜心”中的另一个，我不记得哪一个是哪一个了。有什么写进来的。
Okay. Or don't. These are but these are I mean we'll get like much as a is a Jared Leto and Housaguchi who write much as his performance is at the level the movie wants to be at. I feel like these two are at the level the movie wants to be at which is cartoonish, you know? Yeah, I mean, it feels very much like Aubrey Plaza
好的。或者不要。这些是，但这些是，我的意思是，我们会得到像杰瑞德·莱托和奥布里·普拉扎那样的人，尽管奥布里·普拉扎的表演达到了电影想要的水平。我觉得这两个人达到了电影想要的水平，也就是卡通化，你知道吗？是的，我的意思是，感觉非常像奥布里·普拉扎
is doing a performance of her character, April Ludgate, doing a performance of this character almost. Yeah. So we're kind of introduced to this drama and these different personalities at a press conference that is held over a scale model of what the city is supposed to look like, I guess, where they're like walking around on, like, what, gantries and like... Now, Roman, you know urban studies stuff.
在表演她的角色，艾普尔·拉德盖特，在表演这个角色。是的。所以我们在一个新闻发布会上被介绍了这个戏剧和这些不同的人格，这个新闻发布会是在城市应该看起来像什么的比例模型上举行的，我想，他们在上面走来走去，就像，什么，龙门架之类的……现在，罗曼，你懂城市研究的东西。
Is this usually how, like, a new city development is unveiled by everyone walking on a catwalk over it, and it's very dimly lit, and people are arguing with each other in the catwalk? Yeah, it's similar to all the ones I've been to, for sure. But is it the dramatic lighting, all this sort of thing? It just, this is where the beginning of the nonsense, especially the big talk with nothing inside of the big talk.
这通常是新城市开发揭幕的方式吗，每个人都在它上面的猫道上走，而且灯光非常昏暗，人们在猫道上互相争吵？是的，这肯定和我去过的所有那些很像。但戏剧性的灯光，所有这些东西是吗？这只是，这是胡言乱语的开始，尤其是大话里什么都没有的大话。
Yeah, well then, apparently Adam Driver had a speech that he was supposed to deliver in this scene, and Coppola, to loosen him up, said, why don't you just go out there and do the to be or not to be, soliloquy from Hamlet, and he did it. And Coppola was like, I like that more. I'll put that in the movie. So that's why Adam Driver goes out and does to be or not to be. And it's a, it's not a bad performance of that soliloquy, but it's the whole, the whole time I was reaching to be
是的，好吧，显然亚当·德赖弗在这个场景中应该发表一段演讲，科波拉为了让他放松，说，你为什么不直接出去做《哈姆雷特》里的“生存还是毁灭”独白呢，他就做了。科波拉说，我更喜欢那个。我会把它放进电影里。所以这就是为什么亚当·德赖弗走出去做“生存还是毁灭”。而且这是一个，这不是一个糟糕的独白表演，但整个，整个时间我都在努力去
like, why is he doing this in this moment? Cause I wasn't yet far enough into the movie to realize there's not really a logical reason for a lot of the things to happen in the movie. So we get a little bit of further backstory. We get, it turns out that Caesar Catalina has a tragic backstory. His wife was potentially, what, like killed by him? Is there, that's the belief is that he may or may not have been involved in her death or a car accident
像，为什么他要在这一刻做这个？因为我还没有深入到电影里去意识到电影中发生的事情并没有真正的逻辑原因。所以我们得到了一点进一步的背景故事。我们得到，事实证明凯撒·卡塔琳娜有一个悲惨的背景故事。他的妻子可能，什么，就像被他杀死了？有，这就是人们认为他可能参与了她的死亡或车祸
that she was injured? She was found, drowned in a car at the bottom of the lake, or bottom of the river, in a shot that is an explicit call to or about of the river in a in a shot that is an Explicit call to the night of the hunter to Shelly Winters in the in the drowned car night of the hunter And so we already know that before he was mayor Giancarlo Esposito was the DA and he brought Adam Driver up on charges and took him to court Accusing him of that murder and he was acquitted of that murder. And so yeah, there's there's bad blood and he's a bad boy It's bad blood over a bad boy. Now, speaking of bad boys.
她受伤了？她被发现，淹死在湖底的一辆车里，或者河底，在一个镜头中，这是一个明确的对《猎人之夜》的呼应，关于在河里的，在一个镜头中，这是一个明确的对《猎人之夜》中谢莉·温特斯在淹没的车里的呼应。所以我们已经知道，在成为市长之前，吉安卡洛·埃斯波西托是地方检察官，他起诉了亚当·德赖弗，并把他带上法庭，指控他谋杀，而他被判无罪。所以是的，有坏血，他是一个坏男孩。坏男孩的坏血。现在，说到坏男孩。
And Driver, ironically, they said that he drove her to death. That is ironic. That's ironic, thanks for explaining irony to me. So he's a bad boy because he's also kind of secretly dating while platinum, and they have this scene where they are kind of hooking up in a very messy hotel room or apartment he kind of spurs her spurns her affections there is the lovely line where she is down on her knees and says
还有德赖弗，讽刺的是，他们说他把她开车开死了。这很讽刺。这很讽刺，谢谢你向我解释讽刺。所以他是一个坏男孩，因为他也偷偷地和普拉特纳姆约会，他们有这个场景，他们在非常凌乱的酒店房间或公寓里鬼混，他有点拒绝了她的爱慕，有一句可爱的台词，她跪在地上说
Caesar your anal is hell luckily I'm oral as hell and I was like hooting and hollering in the theater academy award winner for the screenplay for Patton who rode that line. Shot off your pistols into the air. Should we set up here one thing when they are in this press conference talking about the different visions for the city. I think the mayor wants to do this sort of garish, you know, Biff style casino in this space. And then Adam Driver's like talking and he quotes Hamlet and stuff. But there's no presentation of what his ideas are really, or did I just miss them?
凯撒，你的肛门是地狱，幸运的是我是口交地狱，我当时在电影院里大喊大叫，奥斯卡金像奖得主为《巴顿》写的剧本，谁写了那句台词。向空中射击你的手枪。我们应该在这里设定一件事吗，当他们在新闻发布会上谈论城市的不同愿景时。我想市长想在这个空间里做一个那种俗气的，你知道，比夫风格的赌场。然后亚当·德赖弗在说话，他引用了《哈姆雷特》之类的。但没有展示他的想法到底是什么，还是我错过了？
No, I think it's kind of taken for granted on his part, I mean the movie's part, that everyone already kind of has a sense of Megalopolis, his dream city that he wants to build. But he does not present, I think that was probably the speech he was gonna give in the original screenplay. Well, that's the thing, also, look, casinos are basically never the answer,
不，我认为这在他这边，我的意思是电影这边，被认为是理所当然的，每个人都已经对“大都会”有了一种感觉，他想建造的梦想城市。但他没有展示，我想那可能是他在原始剧本中要发表的演讲。好吧，这就是那件事，而且，看，赌场基本上从来都不是答案，
but the way it's at least presented. They're the answer to where can I get a cheap steak at three in the morning? The way it is at least presented here is the mayor's like hey, you've got all these, you know behind the sky ideas But like there are people who need things right now And I'm going to give them to them and in the absence of Adam drivers character having any argument I'm like, I don't know. It sounds like he's making some sense like why am I supposed to? Sympathize immediately with Adam Driver? Because he can stop time? Great.
但至少它是这样呈现的。它们是“我在凌晨三点能在哪里吃到便宜牛排”的答案。至少在这里呈现的方式是市长说，嘿，你有很多，你知道，天马行空的想法，但有些人现在需要东西，我要给他们。在亚当·德赖弗的角色没有任何论点的情况下，我想，我不知道。听起来他很有道理，为什么我应该立即同情亚当·德赖弗？因为他能停止时间？太棒了。
But he says something to the effect of like, let's just give the people what they want. We need to serve the people. And this is the way we serve the people at this casino. And then Adam Driver offers, right, no counter argument whatsoever. So I was trying to get like, this is my, this is the beginning of my frustration with this movie. Up till now, you were totally on board. You were like, this is my, this is the beginning of my frustration with this movie is like, is like-
但他说了类似“让我们给人们他们想要的”之类的话。我们需要服务人民。这就是我们在赌场服务人民的方式。然后亚当·德赖弗提供了，对吧，没有任何反驳。所以我试图得到，这是我的，这是我对这部电影沮丧的开始。到目前为止，你完全支持。你当时就像，这是我的，这是我对这部电影沮丧的开始，就像——
Up till now you were totally on board. Yeah. I love it. I love it. Yeah, you showed up wearing a Caesar Catalina t-shirt. Foam finger and everything. But it's, if you're going to be broad stroke fables, then you have to present ideas. You know what I mean?
到目前为止你完全支持。是的。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。是的，你穿着凯撒·卡塔琳娜的T恤出现。泡沫手指什么的。但它是，如果你要成为大笔触的寓言，那么你必须提出想法。你知道我的意思吗？
Like if the characters are not gonna make sense and they're gonna be completely arched and not have natural dialogue. If the sets are all fantastical and stuff, that usually means that you're clearing the way of all this nuance so you can tell, like a war of ideas of good and evil or whatever. And this is where I begin to like,
就像如果角色没有意义，他们将完全是拱形的，没有自然的对话。如果布景全是奇幻的之类的，那通常意味着你正在清除所有这些细微差别，这样你就可以讲述，比如善与恶的战争之类的。这就是我开始像，
what is the premise of Megalopolis? You know, like what does he, what does this utopia mean other than the word utopia? What is the casino? Like, is it really about serving the people? Is it about corruption? Is it about both? None of these things are clear here.
《大都会》的前提是什么？你知道，除了“乌托邦”这个词，这个乌托邦对他意味着什么？赌场是什么？就像，它真的是关于服务人民吗？它是关于腐败吗？它是关于两者吗？这些事情在这里都不清楚。
And I'm just like, I'm just at sea with this idea of like, and so much of'm just like, I'm just at sea with this idea of like, and so much of it is like, is that the deflation of this moment of like, oh, it isn't that Caesar is a Moses like figure. It's, oh, he is just a genius. Like he's just great. That's the- Yeah.
我只是，我只是对这个想法感到迷茫，而且其中很多，我只是对这个想法感到迷茫，而且其中很多就像，是那一刻的泄气，就像，哦，凯撒不是一个摩西式的人物。它是，哦，他只是一个天才。就像他很棒。那是——是的。
I mean, that's the thing kind of Elliot pointed out. Like it'd be one thing if the idea was that Caesar is this guy who he believes that people don't understand what they actually want or need and that he's at odds with the mayor and there's an actual question as to which one who's right. But the movie is like, nope, Caesar's right. You got to listen to the smart guy. I really think one of the way that it makes sense to me is just if I look at it as a metaphor for Francis Ford Coppola, the genius.
我的意思是，这就是埃利奥特指出的那种东西。如果想法是凯撒是一个人，他认为人们不明白他们真正想要或需要什么，并且他与市长不和，并且实际上有一个问题是哪一个谁是对的，那是一回事。但电影就像，不，凯撒是对的。你得听那个聪明人的话。我真的认为它对我来说有意义的一种方式是，如果我把它看作是弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉，那个天才的隐喻。
And the mayor is a studio executive and he's saying, make me a superhero movie. We got to serve the people and that's what they want. They want a flashy casino. And Francis Ford Coppola is like, no, I want to build them the movies of the future that will create new ways to think and feel. And I have this new element, Copalan, I mean, Megalon, like that's the only way. And I don't know if it's that explicit in his head or if that was his intention, but that's the way I can read it as a metaphor where it starts to make sense.
而市长是一个电影公司高管，他说，给我拍一部超级英雄电影。我们必须服务人民，这就是他们想要的。他们想要一个华丽的赌场。而弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉说，不，我想为他们建造未来的电影，这将创造新的思考和感受方式。而且我有这个新元素，科波兰，我的意思是，美加隆，就像那是唯一的方法。我不知道这在他的脑海里是否那么明确，或者那是否是他的意图，但这就是我可以把它读作一个隐喻的方式，它开始有意义了。
You know? But that's the only thing that makes, that's the only way it makes sense. But he also seems to think that it makes sense on a political level of like, this is a story about politics and populism versus... It's one of the things where it's like, obviously populism is bad. We need a genius who can cut through things. And it's like, well, that's fascism. Like, that's like, like you're like, like the thing you present is like the mob gone
你知道吗？但这确实是唯一能让事情说得通的解释。但他似乎也认为这在政治层面上讲得通，比如，这是一个关于政治和民粹主义的故事，对抗……这属于那种显而易见民粹主义很糟糕的情况。我们需要一个能解决问题的天才。而这就像是，嗯，那就是法西斯主义。就像你所呈现的东西是暴民变得
unruly. Your only solution is that we all just trust Adam Driver's magic metal, you know. But that's the thing, like, as you're doing the synopsis, that the main thing that is like to be conveyed about this moment is that the ideas are almost there as if there's some kind of thing to be said or some point, but they don't connect. And instead it just moves on, you know, like,
难以控制。你唯一的解决方案就是我们大家都去相信亚当·德赖弗那神奇的金属，你知道的。但问题就在于，当你做剧情梗概时，关于这一刻最需要传达的主要内容是，这些想法几乎就在那儿了，好像有什么话要说或者有什么观点，但它们并没有联系起来。相反，它只是继续向前，你知道，就像，
and it's very, very weird. That's what I was like, I was like, what is it? What does it mean to serve the people with a casino? Who, I just like these ideas, like none of them stick. None of them are consistent and it just keeps rolling on. I think John Carlos Vizito or Mayor Cicero, my mistake, his plan actually, there is something, he's saying, we need to build a casino because it'll, like, the people want it. At least that's a concrete thing explanation. Like, I can at least understand
而且这非常、非常奇怪。我当时就在想，这是什么？用赌场来服务人民意味着什么？谁，我只是喜欢这些想法，但它们一个都没立住。它们没有一个是连贯的，而且它就一直这么演下去。我想约翰·卡洛斯·维齐托或者西塞罗市长，抱歉，他的计划实际上，是有那么点意思，他在说，我们需要建一个赌场，因为这会，就像，人民想要它。至少这是一个具体的解释。就像，我至少能理解
that. I mean, we learn more about what Magalopolis will be like later. You'll get to it Stuart, the plant buildings and the glowing moving sidewalks. The plant buildings are home for everyone with apparently tons of space now. I don't know. I'm like, did half the population die? Did everybody get... I mean, you'll see, there's a disaster that opens up quite a bit of extra space for building. 15 minutes is two and a half hours.
那个。我的意思是，我们稍后会更多地了解“大都会”会是什么样子。你会看到的，斯图尔特，那些植物建筑和发光的移动人行道。植物建筑是每个人的家，显然现在有大量的空间。我不知道。我在想，是一半人口死掉了吗？大家都……我的意思是，你会看到的，有一场灾难开启了相当多的额外建筑空间。15分钟就是两个半小时。
I'm sorry for moving us backward when we should be moving forward. So this scene happens, you realize, it has a relationship with Wild Platinum. With Wild Platinum, exactly. I kind of enjoy that name. That was one where I was like, I'm into that. I mean, everything about Aubrey Plaza's performance and character is on the level of a political
很抱歉让我们倒退，而我们本应该前进。所以这一幕发生了，你意识到，它和“狂野白金”有关系。和“狂野白金”，没错。我有点喜欢这个名字。那是让我觉得，我对此很感兴趣的一个点。我的意思是，奥布瑞·普拉扎的表演和角色的方方面面都处于一种政治
editorial cartoon, which is kind of where this movie wants to exist, you know? And she knows how to play these characters, you know? Meanwhile, Julia Cicero bluffs her way into the office of Caesar Catalina. And we have a little bit of a verbal sparring between the two of them. She wants to get in on this Caesar Catalina department of this design authority stuff. And he is initially, go on. Well she like sent him like a letter to insult him, right? And she wants it back because she doesn't want
社论漫画的水平，这正是这部电影想要存在的层面，你知道吗？而且她知道如何扮演这些角色，你知道吗？与此同时，朱莉娅·西塞罗虚张声势地闯进了凯撒·卡塔利娜的办公室。我们两人之间进行了一点口头交锋。她想加入凯撒·卡塔利娜的设计权威部门。而他最初，继续。好吧，她给他寄了一封信来侮辱他，对吧？她想要回那封信，因为她不想
to embarrass her dad. She also like, but she's also like, I think she's interested in him. She saw him stop time for God's sakes. Andy looks like Adam Driver. Andy looks like Adam Driver. Andy looks like Adam Driver, which is not to everyone's taste, but you know, most people. And this is where he tells her to go back to the club,
让她爸爸难堪。她也，但她也，我想她对他感兴趣。天哪，她看到他让时间停止了。安迪看起来像亚当·德赖弗。安迪看起来像亚当·德赖弗。安迪看起来像亚当·德赖弗，这并不符合每个人的口味，但你知道，大多数人。这就是他让她回到俱乐部的地方，
which is a moment that in context, it does not seem as bonkers as it does when it's clipped out. A fun reading is what it is. It's a fun line reading. And he's trying to make fun of the idea of the cool club. He also, this is also where he says like, why do you deserve to make fun of the idea of the cool club. He also, this is also where he says like, like what, why do you deserve to be exposed to the riches
这在语境中，看起来并不像被剪辑出来时那么疯狂。这是一种有趣的台词解读。这是一种有趣的台词解读。他试图嘲笑那个酷俱乐部的想法。他还，这也是他说为什么你值得嘲笑那个酷俱乐部的想法的地方。他还，这也是他说，就像什么，为什么你值得接触到
of my Emersonian mind or whatever, which is also a very funny line. Yeah. It's great. And then he like, It's everyone on Twitter. Yeah, it's great. He then takes her, he then takes her to a, a skate,
我那爱默生式的思想或什么的财富，这也是一句非常有趣的台词。是的。太棒了。然后他就像，这是推特上的每个人。是的，太棒了。然后他带她，他带她去了一个，一个滑板，
a not, probably not perfectly to scale cardboard model of the city and has her walk through it with her eyes closed and she pictures the megalopolis that could be, you know, with again, like floating walkways and streets and everything's glowing and it looks like it's made out of plants, it's super bio-organic. It looks like every CGI rendering proposal
一个，可能不是完全按比例缩小的城市纸板模型，让她闭着眼睛走过它，她想象着可能存在的大都会，你知道，再次，就像漂浮的人行道和街道，一切都在发光，看起来像是用植物做的，超级生物有机。它看起来就像每一个纽约摩天大楼的
of a skyscraper in New York, when they're like, here's what we're going to do with this space that opened up. And it's always a CGI rendering where everything's super glossy and there's trees all over and... Yeah, it looks like the cover of a super melodic Tech Death album cover, you know. Exactly. And I also hate to slow us down, but in terms of like the look of this film...
CGI渲染提案，当他们说，这是我们要对这个空出来的空间做的事情。而且它总是一个CGI渲染图，一切都超级光亮，到处都是树，而且……是的，它看起来像一张超级旋律死亡金属专辑的封面，你知道。没错。而且我也不想拖慢我们的进度，但就这部电影的视觉效果而言……
I hate to slow us down, but... In terms of like the look of this film. I hate to slow us down, but in terms of... I'd like to do the Bob and Ray Slow Talkers of America sketch. Great sketch. The look of this movie is all over the place, partly I assume because, you know, some of it was filmed years ago and then some of it was filmed more recently and it was all sort of jammed together and you know he it's what affects i mean even though this is 120 million dollars of his own money it wasn't enough and like it's what he could afford in certain scenes like but i think that
我不想拖慢我们的进度，但……就这部电影的视觉效果而言。我不想拖慢我们的进度，但就……我想做鲍勃和雷的“美国慢谈者”小品。很棒的小品。这部电影的视觉效果到处都是，我假设部分原因是，你知道，其中一些是几年前拍摄的，然后一些是最近拍摄的，它们被胡乱拼凑在一起，你知道他，这是什么影响，我的意思是，尽管这是他自己掏的1.2亿美元，但这还不够，就像这是他在某些场景中能负担得起的，但我认为
there's some scenes that are genuinely like beautiful and visually striking and some of them look like maybe a C tier CGI effects companies reel and some of it looks like they got it off of Storyblocks or something. There's some beautiful stuff on there, a former... Storyblocks has a lot of great footage, but it's not what you would expect from a major motion picture. Yeah, it's odd to see what seems to be stock footage just sort of interspersed in this thing. So they were making a documentary about them making this movie at the same time they're making the movie,
有些场景确实很美，视觉上很引人注目，而有些场景看起来可能像是一个C级CGI特效公司的作品集，还有一些看起来像是他们从Storyblocks之类的网站上弄来的。上面有一些很美的东西，一个前……Storyblocks有很多很棒的素材，但这不是你对一部大型电影的期待。是的，看到似乎是库存素材的东西穿插在这部电影里很奇怪。所以他们在制作这部电影的同时也在拍摄一部关于他们制作这部电影的纪录片，
and it hasn't come out yet. And I'm so curious to watch it, because I have to imagine there were huge swaths of the film that were changed at the last minute because of budget reasons and things like that. So the mayor finds out that his daughter's been spending some time with Caesar and he's not a big fan of this. Right around now he has a parade and everybody's like mean to him and don't like him.
而且它还没上映。我很好奇想看它，因为我不得不想象电影中有很大一部分是因为预算原因而在最后一刻被修改的。所以市长发现他女儿一直在和凯撒待在一起，他不太喜欢这样。就在这时，他举行了一场游行，每个人都对他很刻薄，不喜欢他。
They're all booing him, yeah. I think also this is where a random guy gets recruited off the street to be one of Claudio's henchmen. I think that's the same guy. The tuba player in the marching band. He gets recruited to go off of Claudio and I'm like, I guess this is going to be one of Claudio's henchmen. I think that's the same guy. The tuba player in the marching band. He gets recruited to go off with Claudio. And I'm like, I guess this is going to be an important character, but it's not really.
他们都在嘘他，是的。我想这也是一个随机的人被从街上招募来成为克劳迪奥的爪牙之一的地方。我想那是同一个人。行进乐队里的那个大号手。他被招募去追随克劳迪奥，我在想，我想这会是克劳迪奥的爪牙之一。我想那是同一个人。行进乐队里的那个大号手。他被招募去和克劳迪奥一起走。我在想，我想这会是一个重要的角色，但其实并不是。
Like they spent a surprising amount of time with the marching band wondering where this guy went to, considering we barely ever see any of them ever again. Okay, fast forward a little bit. It is nighttime, Caesar jumps in his car and goes driving through the rainy streets of New Rome. He is pursued by Claudio and Julia in separate cars. We have like a little rainy street chase, I guess.
就像他们花在行进乐队身上的时间出奇地多，想知道这家伙去哪了，考虑到我们几乎再也没见过他们中的任何一个人。好吧，快进一点。是晚上了，凯撒跳进他的车，开车穿过新罗马下雨的街道。他被克劳迪奥和朱莉娅分别开车追赶。我们有了一场雨中街道追逐戏，我想。
And this is where we have one of the, there are a couple moments in this movie that I do think are brilliant and beautiful. And this is where he's going driving through the city and he's seeing the statues of the city, these huge kind of Greco-Roman type statues, are literally sagging out of fatigue and dropping the things they're holding and leaning against buildings. And it's like, I think it's such a, it's a beautiful way of getting across the idea of a society that has exhausted itself, that is losing the energy that made it great once. And I'm like, oh, this is a, the kind of beautiful straightforward metaphor that he's not achieving
这就是我们有的其中一个，这部电影里有几个时刻我认为是辉煌而美丽的。这就是他开车穿过城市，看到城市的雕像，这些巨大的希腊罗马式雕像，因为疲惫而真正地塌陷，丢掉它们拿着的东西，靠在建筑物上。这就像，我认为这是一种，这是一种美丽的方式来传达一个已经耗尽了自己、正在失去曾经使其伟大的能量的社会的概念。我在想，哦，这是一种，他没有在电影大部分时间里实现的那种美丽的直接隐喻。
through most of the movie. In my opinion. Right, well it's a sort of directly expressionist look that I think part of the problem is it doesn't settle on one thing. If it was all sort of poetic in the same way, it would feel better, but there's a lot of disjointed different ways of doing it.
在我看来。没错，这是一种直接的表现主义外观，我认为问题的一部分在于它没有定格在一件事上。如果它以同样的方式保持诗意，感觉会更好，但它有很多不连贯的表达方式。
Yeah. I had the same feeling when I saw this. This scene was the most where I was like, oh, this is what this kind of fantastical imagery is. This is where it's achieving what I think it's supposed to be achieving the whole time. This is where it hit me. And I was like, I can deal with this artifice. I can deal with the fact that this all feels like green screen, but not, you know, like
是的。我看到这时也有同样的感觉。这一幕是我最觉得，哦，这就是这种奇幻意象是什么。这就是它实现了我认为它一直应该实现的目标的地方。这就是它打动我的地方。我在想，我可以接受这种人为感。我可以接受这一切感觉像绿幕，但不是，你知道，那种
purposeful, you know, kind of green screen. And it just felt that, that was my favorite visual moment in the whole movie was the statues and the, and the sort of dilapidated parts of New Rome. That worked on me totally. And it's, it's a bit of a sledgehammer, but I feel like it is very clear what it's trying to say. It's not as messy as some of the other stuff. But that's where it delivers being a fable, is the thing. That's like, I want it to, yeah.
有目的的，你知道，那种绿幕。这感觉，那是我整部电影中最喜欢的视觉时刻，那些雕像和新罗马那些破败的部分。这完全打动了我。而且，这有点像大锤，但我感觉它试图表达的内容非常清晰。它不像其他一些东西那么混乱。但这就是它作为寓言发挥作用的地方，就是这样。就像，我希望它，是的。
I want it to be a fable. Yeah, yeah, when you saw those statues, you're like, we have title finally. So... Rob and I have a movie for you called The Fableman's that you might enjoy more. Yeah, it's a real fable, yeah. Fable oriented.
我希望它成为一个寓言。是的，是的，当你看到那些雕像时，你会想，我们终于有了标题。所以……罗伯和我有一部电影要推荐给你，叫《造梦之家》，你可能会更喜欢。是的，这是一个真正的寓言，是的。以寓言为导向。
It's about a little mouse. So... Oh, that's Fable Goes West, I apologize. It's an American Tale, Fable oriented. It's about a little mouse. That's Fable Goes West. I apologize. It's an American Tale, Fable Goes West. Caesar's car stops in front of a mysterious, glowing flower stall that appears in the middle of the street. Julia sees this and says, that doesn't make sense. And I'm like, it doesn't make sense. You're right.
是关于一只小老鼠的。所以……哦，那是《美国鼠谭》，抱歉。它是以寓言为导向的。是关于一只小老鼠的。那是《美国鼠谭》。我道歉。它是《美国鼠谭》，以寓言为导向。凯撒的车停在出现在街道中间的一个神秘的发光花摊前。朱莉娅看到这一幕说，这说不通。我在想，这确实说不通。你说得对。
And then he takes the flowers he buys and goes up into a dilapidated apartment building. She pursues him. In his mind, he sees that he's walking into like a well-appointed room with attendants and his wife is in the bed. But in reality, he's just like sitting on a bed, right? Like there's no wife there at all.
然后他拿着他买的花走进了一栋破旧的公寓楼。她追着他。在他的脑海里，他看到他走进了一个设施齐全的房间，有侍从，他的妻子在床上。但实际上，他只是坐在床上，对吧？就像那里根本没有妻子。
He's like- He's hallucinating that his wife is still alive and is being cared for, and he's visiting her. And Julia seems to see both reality and the hallucination. Like she will seize reality, but seems to understand, oh, he thinks his wife is there. And Claudio is also spying on this as well,
他就像——他产生幻觉，以为他的妻子还活着，正在接受照顾，而他正在探望她。朱莉娅似乎既看到了现实，也看到了幻觉。就像她会看到现实，但似乎明白，哦，他以为他的妻子在那里。克劳迪奥也在监视这一切，
but he doesn't see the hallucination, I don't believe. It's also... I never could quite figure out why... I know why Claudio gets mad later. I could never quite figure out why Claudio cares about Caesar right now. He has like a burn book of all the people he doesn't like and Caesar Catalina's written down on that. Maybe that's it, this character doesn't need a motivation.
但他并没有看到幻觉，我不相信。这也是……我从来没能完全弄清楚为什么……我知道为什么克劳迪奥后来生气了。我从来没能完全弄清楚为什么克劳迪奥现在关心凯撒。他有一本他不喜欢的人的黑名单，凯撒·卡塔利娜的名字写在上面。也许就是这样，这个角色不需要动机。
I mean, and Shia LaBeouf, I think he's harnessing his natural unlikability for this character in a really strong way. No, that's true, you don't need a backstory. You're like, oh, this guy's just, you know, he's just a jerk. He doesn't like this guy. Yeah, I just assumed that Caesar Catalina, like, I don't know, accidentally threw some logs in the fire when they're sitting around the fire
我的意思是，还有希亚·拉博夫，我认为他正在以一种非常强烈的方式利用他天生的不讨人喜欢来塑造这个角色。不，那是真的，你不需要背景故事。你会想，哦，这家伙只是，你知道，他只是个混蛋。他不喜欢这家伙。是的，我只是假设凯撒·卡塔利娜，我不知道，不小心往火里扔了一些木头，当他们坐在火边时，
and it burned off Shia LaBeouf's eyebrows. So that's why he hates him because he has he has like painted on eyebrows or something. Yeah, just like Superman and like Luther. OK, so shortly after this, I guess it's like the next eyebrows or something. Yeah, just like Superman and Lex Luthor, yeah. Okay, so shortly after this, I guess it's like the next day or something, Caesar takes Julia up in his private elevator to the top of the Design Authority, where he has his, I don't know, like thinking area, which is like a clock on its side and a bunch of ledges and girders. It looks kind of like the... To me, it looked like a set for like a play on its side and a bunch of ledges and girders that looks kind of like the, to me it looked like a set for like a play, right?
烧掉了希亚·拉博夫的眉毛。所以这就是他恨他的原因，因为他有画上去的眉毛之类的。是的，就像超人和卢瑟。好吧，所以在这之后不久，我想是第二天左右，凯撒带着朱莉娅乘他的私人电梯到了设计权威部门的顶层，那里有他的，我不知道，就像思考区，那是一个侧放的时钟和一堆壁架和梁。它看起来有点像……对我来说，它看起来像一个舞台布景，侧放着，有一堆壁架和梁，看起来有点像，对我来说，它看起来像一个舞台布景，对吧？
And where they can like gaze down upon all of New Rome and kind of see as everything moves. And it's sort of like they're hanging out on top of like a mobile, like you put over either a baby or you'd have an art gallery on either side of the sort of spectrum of mobiles. I think around now he kind of explains what he's doing or what he's thinking, but I don't really remember
在那里他们可以俯瞰整个新罗马，看着一切移动。这有点像他们挂在一个移动装置上，就像你放在婴儿上方，或者你在移动装置光谱的两边都有一个艺术画廊。我想大约在这个时候，他解释了他在做什么或他在想什么，但我真的不记得
this scene outside of them just hanging out on clocks. Yeah. Meanwhile... I think there's nothing, in my notes, there's nothing particular, my notes, there's nothing particular. It just says clocks. Meanwhile, we get a wedding between Wild Platinum and Crassus the Banker Guy. I don't remember his last name. Is that his last name?
这一幕了，除了他们只是挂在时钟上。是的。与此同时……我想没什么，在我的笔记里，没什么特别的，在我的笔记里，没什么特别的。它只写了时钟。与此同时，我们看到了“狂野白金”和克拉苏那个银行家之间的婚礼。我不记得他的姓了。那是他的姓吗？
I think Crassus is his last name. Yeah, that's John Voight. So this is clearly Wild Platinum, this is a power play for her. She wants access to his money. He is Hamilton Crassus III. Thank you. Hamilton Crassus III. Thank you.
我想克拉苏是他的姓。是的，那是强·沃特。所以这显然是“狂野白金”，这对她来说是一场权力游戏。她想要获得他的钱。他是汉密尔顿·克拉苏三世。谢谢。汉密尔顿·克拉苏三世。谢谢。
And so we have a big fancy wedding. It has, it's a wedding that has everything. It has gladiators. It has guys riding chariots around on the inside of a coliseum. Caesar shows up and a pop star shows up wearing a dress made out of... That was this wedding. Yeah. To me, honestly guys, I was just like, oh, they all went to the circus.
所以我们有了一场盛大的豪华婚礼。它有，这是一场拥有一切的婚礼。它有角斗士。它有在斗兽场内骑战车的家伙。凯撒出现了，一个流行歌星穿着一件由……做的裙子出现了。那就是这场婚礼。是的。对我来说，老实说伙计们，我只是想，哦，他们都去了马戏团。
And I was like, fine with that as an explanation. I'm just like, they're at the circus now. Like the March Brothers. It's a celebration of their betrothal though, right? Maybe it's for a reception, who knows. Yeah, but that's why they're doing it. Yeah, and there's a pop star wearing, I can't remember if this is the same pop star from later,
我对此解释很满意。我只是想，他们现在在马戏团。就像马奇兄弟。不过这是为了庆祝他们的订婚，对吧？也许是为了招待会，谁知道呢。是的，但这就是他们这么做的原因。是的，还有一个流行歌星穿着，我不记得这是否是后来那个流行歌星，
Vesta Sweetwater, who shows up wearing a dress made out of Megalon. Yes, this is Vesta Sweetwater. This Megalon dress is perfect camouflage. Does not matter for later. There's no moment where you're like, oh, you can use Megalon if you cover yourself like the Predator can't see you or something. That doesn't matter.
维斯塔·斯威特沃特，她穿着一件由“梅加隆”做的裙子出现了。是的，这就是维斯塔·斯威特沃特。这件梅加隆裙子是完美的伪装。对后来没影响。没有一个时刻你会想，哦，如果你遮住自己，你可以使用梅加隆，这样铁血战士就看不见你了之类的。那不重要。
No, it's just a one-off idea that it's a dress made out of Megalon where there's cameras in the back that project what's behind you on the front, so you turn invisible. And that's it. It's just an effect. There's a ton of Roman stuff. We haven't really even talked about the outfits and stuff.
不，这只是一个一次性的想法，它是一件由梅加隆制成的裙子，后面有摄像头，把背后的东西投射到前面，所以你隐形了。就是这样。这只是一个特效。有很多罗马的东西。我们甚至还没谈论服装之类的。
Like everybody has like vaguely futuristic Roman outfits. You know it's futuristic because like men's suits have slightly different collar cuts. Yeah. Sometimes they don't have, it's like a severe suit cut, but they also have little, they have like little laurel wreaths behind their ear, you knowreaths behind their ears. So it's like...
就像每个人都有模糊的未来派罗马服装。你知道它是未来派的，因为男士西装有稍微不同的领口剪裁。是的。有时他们没有，就像一种严厉的西装剪裁，但他们也有小的，他们有小的月桂花环在耳后，你知道。所以就像……
Kind of epaulettes to make them, like, their shoulders very broad, lots of capes and stuff like that. It's the kind of stuff that has been done on stage in productions of Julius Caesar since at least the 1930s. Where it's like, we'll pull out how it's like modern political times by having everyone wear suits, but they still have like Roman haircuts. You know, that kind of thing. You know, Roman talked earlier about
有点像肩章，让他们的肩膀看起来很宽，有很多斗篷之类的东西。这是自20世纪30年代以来在《朱利叶斯·凯撒》的舞台制作中就一直被使用的东西。就像，我们将通过让每个人穿西装来展现现代政治时代，但他们仍然有罗马发型。你知道，那种东西。你知道，罗曼之前谈到
when the movie started to sort of lose him, and I want to present- I think he meant when he lost himself in the film. You lost yourself in the moment. You know, I want to talk about the inverse where the movie, which up until this point, had only baffled and dismayed me, started to get me a little bit. And that during this whole circus sequence,
电影开始让他失去兴趣的时候，我想提出——我想他是指他在电影中迷失了自己。你在那一刻迷失了自己。你知道，我想谈谈相反的情况，这部电影，直到这一点，一直让我感到困惑和沮丧，开始让我有点感觉了。在那整个马戏团序列中，
I'm like, oh, it started to engage me in spite of myself, partly because I was like, oh, I don't need to care what any of it means. At least the movie at this point was throwing a bunch of stuff at me. And I appreciated that. This is one of the sequences maybe before they started running out of money.
我在想，哦，它开始不顾一切地吸引我了，部分原因是我在想，哦，我不需要关心这一切意味着什么。至少电影在这一点上向我抛出了一堆东西。我很欣赏这一点。这可能是他们在开始没钱之前的序列之一。
It felt very full of splendor and ideas and none of it necessarily hung together in any thematic way that made any sense to me. But I'm like, oh, okay, movie. It's kind of delivering the bread and circuses to placate people in the audience. Yeah, I'm one of the idiot rabble. Yeah.
它感觉充满了辉煌和想法，没有任何东西在主题上以任何对我来说有意义的方式联系在一起。但我在想，哦，好吧，电影。它有点像是在提供面包和马戏团来安抚观众。是的，我是白痴暴民之一。是的。
Yeah. You're like, finally, I can relate to someone in the movie, the people screaming for blood in the stands. It is thrown a lot. But I think the point, which is easy to get into, is the sneering at the wealthy and you know, sneering at their excess and stuff like that. And it just, it's totally, I mean, it works, that works.
是的。你会想，终于，我可以和电影里的某个人产生共鸣了，那些在看台上尖叫着要血的人。它确实抛出了很多东西。但我认为，容易进入的重点是嘲笑富人，你知道，嘲笑他们的过度行为之类的。而且它完全，我的意思是，它有效，那有效。
And Caesar seems to be doing his best to play along, but he is clearly kind of disgusted by this whole situation. He ends up getting very drunk and getting himself into trouble. Meanwhile, scheming little Claudio, who is, I think he's in drag at this point, he sneaks into like the control booth
凯撒似乎在尽力配合，但他显然对整个情况感到厌恶。他最终喝得大醉，给自己惹了麻烦。与此同时，阴险的小克劳迪奥，我想他此时穿着女装，他溜进了控制室，
and he frames Caesar and Vesta Sweetwater, who is a Taylor Swift style pop star, and the idea is that she is supposed to be a young virgin, right? Yes, she's both made a big deal out of, I'm going to keep myself a virgin, and she's presenting herself as being younger than she is. Which we will learn later.
他陷害了凯撒和维斯塔·斯威特沃特，她是一个泰勒·斯威夫特风格的流行歌星，而这个想法是她应该是一个年轻的处女，对吧？是的，她既大肆宣扬，我要保持处女之身，又表现得比实际年龄小。我们稍后会知道。
Yeah, this is statutory rape, it seems, but it's not, yeah. Yeah, this is like statutory rape, it seems, but it's not actually. Yeah, but isn't the premise of all this, like that these old men, the old rich oligarchy is betting on her virginity, like betting, is that happening? I believe that's true, yes. They're like betting that she's gonna keep her promise,
是的，这看起来像是法定强奸，但并不是，是的。是的，这看起来像是法定强奸，但实际上并不是。是的，但这一切的前提不是说这些老男人，老富有的寡头在赌她的贞操，就像赌博，那是真的吗？我相信那是真的，是的。他们就像在赌她会信守诺言，
right, like they're not auctioning off her virginity, right? I thought that's what that was happening there. Like that, but you guys took notes, I didn't. Somehow the economy of the city is balanced on her promise of staying a virgin until marriage. Yeah. Yeah, I thought they were sort of like bidding to keep her a virgin somehow,
对吧，就像他们不是在拍卖她的贞操，对吧？我以为那就是在那里发生的事情。就像那样，但你们做了笔记，我没有。不知何故，城市的经济平衡在她的婚前保持处女的承诺上。是的。是的，我以为他们有点像是在竞标以某种方式让她保持处女，
but I don't know what the mechanics of that would be. I mean, it's ancient Rome stuff though, because it's like, right? Like the Vestal Virgins, their virginity was one of the things underpinning the safety of spiritual safety of Rome. And so like, that's part of the issue with trying to compare, do a metaphor where you're like, ancient Rome is like nowadays, is that the basic foundational underpinnings of society are so different compared to ancient Rome.
但我不知道那背后的机制会是什么。我的意思是，这是古罗马的东西，因为就像，对吧？就像维斯塔贞女，她们的贞操是支撑罗马精神安全的基石之一。所以，这就是试图做一个隐喻，说古罗马就像现在，的问题的一部分，是社会的基本基础与古罗马相比太不同了。
And like Rome, yeah, they had a Senate. Yeah, that's true. But also like religion and politics were the same thing. And like, it was just taken for granted that if the city was having trouble, you'd make some sacrifices to the gods and hopefully that'll keep things right. The way you thought like- In a way, don't we do that these days, Alan.
而且就像罗马，是的，他们有参议院。是的，那是真的。但也像宗教和政治是一回事。而且，人们理所当然地认为，如果城市遇到麻烦，你会向神灵献祭，希望这能让事情好转。你以为就像——从某种意义上说，我们现在不也这样做吗，艾伦。
You're right, I'm the one who's being naive. Yeah. But I did interpret this as way more sinister than maybe it was. Yeah, I might now say fundraiser, question mark, pledging for purity, question mark. Yeah, I think they are, I think it's like a marathon fundraiser.
你说得对，我是那个天真的人。是的。但我确实把这解释得比它可能的样子更险恶。是的，我现在可能会说筹款活动，问号，承诺纯洁，问号。是的，我想他们是，我想这就像一场马拉松筹款活动。
Where like you're pledging someone to run a marathon. I think they're pledging for her to just stay a virgin. And so when they see her on tape, supposedly in bed with Caesar Catalina. Yeah, they're like, I wasted all that money. Yeah, and everybody, and they're like, oh, the underpinning of our city is all wrong. Yeah.
就像你承诺某人跑马拉松一样。我想他们是在承诺她保持处女。所以当他们在录像带上看到她，据称和凯撒·卡塔利娜在床上。是的，他们就像，我浪费了那么多钱。是的，每个人，他们就像，哦，我们城市的基石全错了。是的。
Yeah, everyone is incensed by this. Like the crowd is, is bang for blood. This is after her big musical number though, right? Yeah, after her big musical number. I didn't talk about it, but do you want to talk about it, Elliott? Do you have opinions? She does this big musical number
是的，每个人都对此感到愤怒。就像人群，是为了血。这是在她的大型音乐表演之后，对吧？是的，在她的大型音乐表演之后。我没谈论它，但你想谈谈吗，埃利奥特？你有意见吗？她做了这个大型音乐表演，
where there's suddenly like six of her singing all at the same time. And again, doesn't make sense. Doesn't really work thematically. Never explained, but it's a cool thing. Not bad. It's a cool looking scene. And I have to say, actually, the Vesta stuff is her, the last we see of her character is one of my favorite moments in the movie also. But we'll get to that. Yeah.
突然有六个她同时在唱歌。而且再次，说不通。在主题上真的行不通。从未解释过，但这是一件很酷的事情。不坏。这是一个看起来很酷的场景。而且我必须说，实际上，维斯塔的东西是她，我们最后一次看到她的角色是我在电影中最喜欢的时刻之一。但我们会谈到的。是的。
Please get to it because I don't have it written down in my notes. Okay. Well, when it's I don't remember it happens here, but like the scandal comes out that this video has been shown by every day to buy, you know, a Shia LaBeouf arranged for this video to be shown on the jumbotron of her in bed with with Adam Driver and then suddenly like the screen fills with fire and
请谈谈它，因为我的笔记里没有写。好吧。好吧，当它——我不记得它发生在这里，但就像丑闻传出，这段视频被每天买，你知道，希亚·拉博夫安排这段视频在巨型屏幕上播放，她和亚当·德赖弗在床上，然后突然屏幕充满了火，
there are headlines that are like, Vesta reimagines herself and suddenly she is singing like a bad girl song. Now she's reimagined herself as like a sinful bad girl and she's a superstar again. And it feels so much like Frances Ford Coppola is like, who are the scenes into? Taylor Swift, what does she do?
有标题写着，维斯塔重塑了自己，突然她唱起了一首坏女孩的歌。现在她把自己重塑成了一个罪恶的坏女孩，她又成了超级巨星。这感觉太像弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉在说，场景是谁的？泰勒·斯威夫特，她做什么？
Okay, I'll do something. This is my understanding of what that is. And it happens so it's like the movie suddenly turns into an advertisement for something else for some other movie Yeah, I think that that's a little sequence that happens a little bit later and it's done like a totally like classic MTV news style Like explosion bit and then like scenes of societal collapse. Okay Adam Driver Caesar Catalina gets too drunk gets beaten up by some guys He gets whisked away. The cops arrest him for statutory rape
好吧，我会做点什么。这是我对那是什么的理解。它发生得太快了，就像电影突然变成了其他东西的广告，为其他电影。是的，我认为那是稍后发生的一小段序列，它做得完全像经典的MTV新闻风格，就像爆炸片段，然后是社会崩溃的场景。好吧，亚当·德赖弗饰演的凯撒·卡塔利娜喝得太醉，被几个家伙打了一顿。他被带走了。警察以法定强奸罪逮捕了他，
because of the video. But then Julia goes into the archives and finds out, actually, Vesta Sweetwater is older than she's been telling everybody, so she exonerates him, problem almost immediately solved. But also, isn't it like- And don't we find out that the video is fake later on? The video's fake too.
因为那个视频。但后来朱莉娅进入档案室发现，实际上，维斯塔·斯威特沃特比她告诉大家的年龄要大，所以她洗清了他的罪名，问题几乎立刻解决了。但，不是吗——而且我们不是后来发现视频是假的吗？视频也是假的。
They like double up the explanations of like, why this is fine. It feels like the movie is fainting towards, fainting F-E-I-N-T, not fainting like, oh, stars and garters. Ooh, like pearls. The vapors, yeah. It's taking a faint towards,
他们就像加倍解释为什么这没问题。感觉电影正在向“佯攻”倾斜，佯攻，F-E-I-N-T，不是昏厥，哦，星星和吊袜带。哦，就像珍珠。蒸汽，是的。它正在向……倾斜，
this guy might be a genius, but he's not a good guy. But instead the movie is very quick to be like, no, no, no, he's a good guy pretending to be a bad guy. And he tells Julia, you gotta pretend to be bad or people lose interest in you or something like that. And they're like, not only was she not a minor, he also didn't have sex with her anyway. So it's fine, he's double good.
这家伙可能是个天才，但他不是个好人。但相反，电影很快就说，不，不，不，他是个假装成坏人的好人。他告诉朱莉娅，你得假装变坏，否则人们会对你失去兴趣之类的。他们就像，她不仅不是未成年人，而且他无论如何也没和她发生性关系。所以没关系，他是双倍的好。
He's nothing to it, he's a sturdling saint. So around now we have Caesar and Julia meeting on top of his girder watch ledge and they have a conversation and with her help he's able to stop time again. He had kind of lost his powers for a little bit. Like Spider-Man, sometimes he loses his powers when he's in a bad mood or depressed.
他什么都没做，他是个圣人。所以大约在这个时候，我们有凯撒和朱莉娅在他的梁观察台上见面，他们进行了交谈，在她的帮助下，他能够再次停止时间。他之前有点失去了他的力量。就像蜘蛛侠，有时他在心情不好或沮丧时会失去力量。
And then they have a kind of sloppy makeout session. I thought that was pretty great. And then we get and they they decide to work together, and we get a montage of them kind of falling in love and doing some work at the design authority. Which by the way, has really boring design. I really wanted those jackets to pop a little bit more. I was really bummed about that,
然后他们进行了一场草率的亲热。我觉得那很棒。然后我们得到，他们决定一起工作，我们得到了一段他们坠入爱河并在设计权威部门做一些工作的蒙太奇。顺便说一句，那里的设计真的很无聊。我真的很想让那些夹克更出彩一点。我对此感到很沮丧，
because I was like, design authority, all right, let's spend some time with design authority. Nothing, nothing. Yeah, yeah. Mugler would be upset. Barbara Moses would be upset. He was all about, say what you will about him in his early work, at least he's got a real design eye.
因为我在想，设计权威，好吧，让我们花点时间在设计权威上。什么都没有，什么都没有。是的，是的。穆格勒会不高兴的。芭芭拉·摩西会不高兴的。他所做的一切，不管你对他早期的作品怎么说，至少他有真正的设计眼光。
Yeah. Claudio, meanwhile, one scheme foiled. He's got more schemes to be had. He starts trumping it up, he sees what's going on and he's like starts getting the getting the masses all angry. They start backing him. Later on there's a scene where he's giving a stump speech and the stump is literally char carved into the shape of a
是的。与此同时，克劳迪奥，一个阴谋失败了。他还有更多的阴谋。他开始煽动，他看到了正在发生的事情，他就像开始让群众都愤怒起来。他们开始支持他。后来有一个场景，他在发表竞选演讲，讲台字面上被雕刻成了
swastika. Is that right? It's pretty messed up. OK. That's I think it's pretty subtle. I don't know. There's nothing like that would happen in this movie. We find out that movie is pretty subtle. I don't know. There's something like that would happen in this movie. We find out that Julia is pregnant. Oh, there's a baby on the way. Master builders build a baby.
纳粹标志的形状。那是真的吗？这太乱了。好吧。我想这很微妙。我不知道。电影里不会发生那种事。我们发现电影很微妙。我不知道。电影里会发生那种事。我们发现朱莉娅怀孕了。哦，有个孩子在路上。建筑大师造了一个孩子。
Mayor Cicero doesn't like this idea. He doesn't like the idea that they're going to have a kid. So he tries to basically tries to buy off Caesar. He's like, hey, you can do whatever you want, just don't, like, leave my daughter out of this. Get out of this. Stuart, you're doing a great job of condensing this movie. Did you skip over the part where the mayor has a dream
西塞罗市长不喜欢这个主意。他不喜欢他们要生孩子的主意。所以他基本上试图收买凯撒。他就像，嘿，你可以做任何你想做的事，只是别，就像，别让我女儿参与进来。离开这个。斯图尔特，你在压缩这部电影方面做得很好。你跳过了市长做梦的那部分吗？
where a cloud with a hand grabs the moon and his wife accurately says that that's an omen? Yeah, okay. Probably. I just want to make sure that we get the full... I'm sorry. I don't want people to listen to this and be like, this movie doesn't sound that crazy. And it's like, oh yeah, what about the scene where the mayor has his dream
云里的一只手抓住了月亮，他的妻子准确地说那是一个预兆？是的，好吧。可能。我只是想确保我们得到完整的……我很抱歉。我不希望人们听这个然后说，这部电影听起来没那么疯狂。就像，哦是的，那市长做梦的那一幕呢？
about a cloud grabbing the moon? Yeah, it doesn't really figure it into much, but it looks cool. I don't know when it happens in the movie, so I just wanna say the visual that has stuck with me, there's like, they're under the water and there's some people who are rocks. They're painted as rocks and then they sort of move
关于云抓住月亮？是的，它并没有真正起到多大作用，但看起来很酷。我不知道它在电影里什么时候发生，所以我只是想说那个一直留在脑海里的视觉效果，就像，他们在水下，有一些人是岩石。他们被漆成岩石，然后他们稍微移动，
and you see that they're people and it is just like half a second. But I was like, that's a really gorgeous image right in the middle of this thing that I'm not sure what it's saying. Yeah, and there's like tons of stuff in here. There's moments where Caesar is like, has like a floating mirror that shows his memories made out of Megalon.
你看到他们是人，这只有半秒钟。但我当时想，那是一个非常华丽的图像，就在这个我不太确定它在说什么的东西中间。是的，这里面有大量的东西。有凯撒就像，有一个漂浮的镜子，显示他用梅加隆制作的记忆的时刻。
And then... Megalon mostly, Megalon is like Herbie the robot from the Fantastic Four cartoon or like, who's the little alien that hung out with the Flintstones? What was that guy's name? The Great Gazoo? The Great Gazoo. The Megalon is just kind of a lump that kind of floats in the air around Caesar's apartment
然后……梅加隆大部分，梅加隆就像《神奇四侠》动画片里的赫比机器人，或者就像，那个和《摩登原始人》混在一起的小外星人是谁？那家伙叫什么名字？伟大的加祖？伟大的加祖。梅加隆只是一个在凯撒公寓周围漂浮的肿块，
and does stuff sometimes, but he'll just be working and the Megalon will kind of float too close to him and have to push it out of the way because it's getting too close to his face. And it's like, it's such a strange, like goofy thing to have, it's like, oh yeah, this is the miracle medal of the future. Anyway, I got a lump of it
有时做点事，但他只是在工作，梅加隆会漂浮得离他太近，不得不把它推开，因为它离他的脸太近了。这就像，这是一种非常奇怪的、愚蠢的东西，就像，哦是的，这是未来的奇迹金属。总之，我有一块，
and it just floats around my apartment. It's kind of irritating. And they have like a family dinner at one point where they invite the mayor and his wife This is the miracle medal of the future anyway. I got a lump of it and it just floats around my apartment. It's kind of irritating. And they have like a family dinner at one point where they invite the mayor and his wife and they're like playing cards in this like weird magical Megalon house, right? Yeah.
它就在我的公寓里漂浮。这有点烦人。他们有一次家庭晚餐，邀请了市长和他的妻子。这是未来的奇迹金属，总之。我有一块，它就在我的公寓里漂浮。这有点烦人。他们有一次家庭晚餐，邀请了市长和他的妻子，他们在这个奇怪的魔法梅加隆房子里玩牌，对吧？是的。
And they're discussing string theory and shit. It's like a Megalopolis exhibit. It's like an exhibit of what Megalops would be like or something like that. Yeah. Does that come after the destruction of the city? That's before the destruction of the city, but after we learn that a Soviet satellite
他们在讨论弦理论之类的。这就像一个大都会展览。这就像一个大都会会是什么样子的展览之类的。是的。那是在城市毁灭之后吗？那是在城市毁灭之前，但在我们得知一颗苏联卫星
is falling to earth and will crash into the city. Why, I forgot about that satellite. There's a Soviet satellite that, yeah, they're like, anyway, its orbit has decayed, it's going to hit the city, and they're like, whoa, and then they don't do anything about it for a while. Yeah, I'm trying to realize that taking these notes in the dark, it was a lot easier to take notes on Madame Webb.
坠向地球并将撞击城市之后。为什么，我忘了那颗卫星。有一颗苏联卫星，是的，他们就像，总之，它的轨道衰变了，它要撞击城市，他们就像，哇，然后他们有一段时间什么都没做。是的，我试图意识到在黑暗中做这些笔记，做《蜘蛛夫人》的笔记容易多了。
A more straightforward film that, you know, follows a screenplay formula that has been entrenched in Hollywood. That's so yeah, by this point, I think we've also, Adam Driver has also kind of shown us his, some of the visual visions of what Megalops looks like and the buildings all look like plants and the ideas like the buildings grow as people need them. Like there's homes for everybody
一部更直接的电影，你知道，遵循好莱坞根深蒂固的剧本公式。所以是的，到这一点，我想我们也，亚当·德赖弗也向我们展示了他的，一些大都会外观的视觉愿景，建筑物看起来都像植物，想法就像建筑物随着人们的需要而生长。就像每个人都有家，
because the buildings can grow and change with the needs of the people, which is a beautiful idea. Roman, how close are we to that? Yeah, I mean- Has anyone tried that yet? Growing buildings? I mean, in a way, like, Hunter Vassar was like really into like mold and letting things grow because it was like true organic space and that the straight line is the godless line and you're gonna want like... Oh, Jeff Fabremere. Of course, he died from the mold in his lungs, I assume.
因为建筑物可以随着人们的需要而生长和改变，这是一个美丽的想法。罗曼，我们离那有多近？是的，我的意思是——有人尝试过吗？种植建筑物？我的意思是，从某种意义上说，亨特·瓦萨真的很喜欢霉菌，让东西生长，因为那是真正的有机空间，直线是无神的线，你会想要……哦，杰夫·法布雷米尔。当然，他死于肺里的霉菌，我假设。
Totally. So there's a lot of, there have been big lofty ideals about a kind of like organic architecture in a, like in a literal way, like to make it. And then there's the term organic architecture, like Frank Lloyd Wright style, that just means it's reactive to, you know, and changes to people's needs. So that's all kind of that those ideas are out there. That is the closest thing this sort of dunderheaded movie gets to an idea. Like that and, and it's the first time you sort of get to this.
完全正确。所以有很多，关于一种有机建筑的崇高理想，以一种字面的方式，就像制造它。然后有“有机建筑”这个词，像弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特风格，那只是意味着它对人们的需求有反应，并随之改变。所以这些想法都在那里。这是这部愚蠢的电影能达到的最接近想法的东西。就像那样，而且这是你第一次接触到这个。
Yeah, like what does this utopia mean that it's that it's like organic and reactive and serves people is actually that that's that it's like organic and reactive and serves people is actually that that's an actual idea. Everything else has just been like glowing walkways and nonsense like where I'm like what is this for? Like what do you have to have like utopias like have to have a concept or something and this one like what is what is the new part of the topia like what does it do? Yeah. It really is. It's really weird. But that's one idea. Like that'd be great.
是的，这个乌托邦意味着什么，它是那种有机的、反应灵敏的、服务于人民的，实际上是——它是有机的、反应灵敏的、服务于人民的，实际上是一个真正的想法。其他一切都只是发光的走廊和胡言乱语，我在想，这是为了什么？就像你必须有乌托邦，必须有一个概念之类的，而这个，就像，乌托邦的新部分是什么，它做什么？是的。它确实是。它真的很奇怪。但这是一个想法。就像那会很棒。
Like having a magical substance that requires like no thought or care or design or whatever. Like politics and it just does its thing. Creates no waste, requires no energy to, it just does it all. And this is like a huge problem. Like that you're going to use some technology that's going to save us rather than people like coming together and actually coming with solutions and working stuff out is like, it's just a nonsense idea that you're exploring for a couple of hours. You say that until Megalon does it works its magic.
就像拥有某种不需要思考、关心或设计之类的神奇物质。就像政治，它只是做它自己的事。不产生浪费，不需要能量，它只是全部完成了。这就像一个巨大的问题。就像你将使用某种能拯救我们的技术，而不是人们团结起来，真正提出解决方案并解决问题，这只是一个你探索了几个小时的胡说八道的想法。你说这话直到梅加隆发挥它的魔力。
Speaking of Megalon working its magic, at this point, Caesar Catalina, probably right on the verge of explaining everything about his utopia, meets with a young 12-year-old fan who actually turns out to be a hired assassin and shoots Caesar in the face. Yeah. Okay, so this is after,
说到梅加隆大显身手，此时，凯撒·卡塔利娜本已准备好解释他乌托邦的一切，却遇到了一位12岁的年轻粉丝，结果对方竟是雇佣杀手，还朝凯撒的脸上开了一枪。没错。好吧，这是在……
this is then after the city is destroyed by a satellite falling to earth, right? Because like, Yeah, maybe. Like this is a, Yeah, This is an amazingly large thing to happen and then not really be addressed that much. We get some scenes of catastrophe, shadows being cast on the wall.
这是在城市被一颗坠落地球的卫星摧毁之后，对吧？因为，嗯，也许吧。这真是一件极其重大的事情，之后却没怎么被提及。我们看到了一些灾难的场景，墙上投射出的阴影。
The reason I bring it up is just because that card game, I was wondering about, one of the things that strikes me about this movie is, as we said, this is a movie that Coppola has been writing for decades and decades. I can only assume that the screenplay grew and grew and grew and at certain points it feels like they just shot every other 20 pages of it.
我之所以提起这个，是因为那个纸牌游戏，我当时就在想，这部电影最让我震惊的一点是，正如我们所说，这是科波拉构思了几十年的电影。我只能推测剧本不断扩充，以至于在某些地方，感觉他们好像只是拍了每隔20页的内容。
Because people's relationships to each other will change wildly between scenes without explanation. Like Juan Carlos Esposito was just saying, like trying to pay off Adam Driver to get away from his daughter. And then in the next scene, they're all sort of like, they don't love each other, but they're having a genial card game together.
因为角色之间的关系在场景之间发生了剧烈的变化，却没有任何解释。就像胡安·卡洛斯·埃斯波西托刚才说的，试图花钱打发亚当·德赖弗离开他的女儿。然后在下一个场景里，他们看起来就像是，虽然他们并不相爱，但却在一起玩着和睦的纸牌游戏。
I'm like, okay, well what happened here? And the only thing I can think of is like, oh, the city was destroyed, so they all game together. I'm like, okay, well what happened here? And the only thing I can think of is like, oh, the city was destroyed, so they all came together. But it's not said or anything. I'm looking at my, because I wasn't sure if I was gonna have to do this summary today or not. So I took some notes also.
我就想，好吧，这到底是怎么回事？我唯一能想到的就是，哦，城市被毁了，所以他们都聚在一起了。我就想，好吧，这到底是怎么回事？我唯一能想到的就是，哦，城市被毁了，所以他们都聚在一起了。但这并没有被说出来或什么的。我看着我的……因为我不确定今天是否需要做这个总结。所以我还做了一些笔记。
Please, please, yeah. But you're right, Dan, because Dustin Hoffman's character, who's an assistant to the mayor, he dies off camera. We hear about, oh yeah, he's dead now. We get one scene of a thing toppling and falling on him. And I'm like, that had to have been a whole sequence.
请，请，没错。但你是对的，丹，因为达斯汀·霍夫曼饰演的角色，也就是市长的助手，他在镜头外死了。我们听说，哦，是的，他现在死了。我们只看到一个东西倒塌压在他身上的场景。我就想，那本该是一整段戏份才对。
And Shia LaBeouf runs for his position of alderman. And his guy, and then it's after that that the mayor goes to Caesar and says, if you leave my daughter, I'll give you the evidence that I lied when I was prosecuting you. And you'll be able to destroy me and I'll put my support behind your projects. And at the same time, wow platinum approaches Catalina, and it's like, hey, look, why don't you come back, be with me again, and you can have all of Crassus' money. Everyone wants to be in the Caesar Catalina business.
然后希亚·拉博夫竞选议员。还有他的人，在那之后市长去找凯撒说，如果你离开我女儿，我就给你证据证明我在起诉你时撒了谎。你就能摧毁我，我会支持你的项目。与此同时，哇·铂金接近卡塔利娜，就像是，嘿，听着，你为什么不回来，再和我在一起，你就能得到克拉苏所有的钱。每个人都想参与凯撒·卡塔利娜的生意。
And he's like, no, no, no. And that's when... Real Catalina Caper. And she seems to hypnotize Crassus into giving her control over the bank. And then Caesar is shot in the head by this child who... He should have been suspicious when a kid asked him to sign his book for him. Like, there's no way this kid is reading Caesar Catalina's book.
而他却说，不，不，不。就在那时……真正的卡塔利娜骗局。她似乎催眠了克拉苏，让他把银行的控制权交给了她。然后凯撒被这个孩子射中了头部，他……当一个孩子让他签名时，他就该起疑心的。毕竟，这孩子根本不可能在读凯撒·卡塔利娜的书。
I don't know, man. Everybody loves Caesar Catalina. I think that's pretty clear. But then, how do they heal him? So he has this moment, at this point, I don't know about you guys, I'm like, wow, they killed him, that's crazy. And he has this weird death dream, but then they end up healing him by fusing his head with some megalon. They just stick megalon on his head, on the open skull that's there, and this truly is an amazing building material.
我不知道，伙计。每个人都爱凯撒·卡塔利娜。我想这一点很清楚。但他们是怎么治好他的呢？所以他经历了这一刻，此时此刻，我不知道你们怎么想，我当时想，哇，他们杀了他，这太疯狂了。他做了一个奇怪的死亡梦，但他们最终通过用一些梅加隆融合他的头部治好了他。他们只是把梅加隆粘在他的头上，粘在那个敞开的头骨上，这确实是一种神奇的建筑材料。
So we, at this point, Caesar then goes... Oh, but then having the megalon in his face gives him lots of like new powers and things like that? Like a multiple man? Yeah, he shows up at Krassus, Hamilton Krassus' apartment. Claudio tries to harass him. Wild Platinum tries to make a move on him. But he reveals his megalon, half human, half megalon face, and it causes multiple images and
所以我们，在这一点上，凯撒然后去……哦，但脸上有梅加隆给了他很多像新能力之类的东西？就像多重人？是的，他出现在克拉苏，汉密尔顿·克拉苏的公寓里。克劳迪奥试图骚扰他。狂野铂金试图对他下手。但他露出了他的梅加隆，半人半梅加隆的脸，这导致了多重影像，并且……
Everybody is wowed by the majesty of his face, especially wow herself And she's like he's he's going there because she's frozen all of his bank accounts using her power at the bank in order to force him to something and and then and then yeah, she offers herself again and Crassus kind of interrupts it But now who does wow set her sights on if she can't control Caesar Catalina? Of course, she's gonna she's gonna pick I guess the next best thing and that's Claudio Crassus. That's right And so she we have a little sex scene. You're probably into this right Dan It was like a like a like a Game of Thrones style
每个人都被他脸上的威严所震撼，尤其是哇本人。她说，他去那里是因为她利用她在银行的权力冻结了他所有的银行账户，以强迫他做某事，然后，然后，是的，她再次献身，克拉苏打断了这一切。但现在，如果哇无法控制凯撒·卡塔利娜，她会把目光投向谁呢？当然，她会选择，我想是下一个最好的选择，那就是克劳迪奥·克拉苏。没错，于是我们有了一场小小的性爱戏。你可能喜欢这个，对吧，丹？这就像是一场《权力的游戏》风格的……
Scene it was kind of like a Game of Thrones style sex scene where it's all about power and yeah Like is this is this what they think sex is like? Or she's like, stick your face in my butt. Okay, now go over there, lie down there. I mean, it can be like that. Yeah, yeah, you're doing it, right? It can be like that, that's true. By the way, I just really love being on this Zoom call
场景，这有点像《权力的游戏》风格的性爱戏，一切都关乎权力，是的。就像，这就是他们认为性爱是什么样子吗？或者她说，把你的脸贴在我的屁股上。好吧，现在去那边，躺在那里。我的意思是，确实可以是那样。是的，是的，你做得对，对吧？确实可以是那样，那是真的。顺便说一句，我真的很喜欢参加这个Zoom通话，
and watching Roman's face as he relives the plot. He's like, oh yeah, that did, that is a thing. Like, what? I have been going through that where I was just like, the satellite, yeah, oh my God. Yeah, I'd forgotten about the satellite. That really is, oh my God, this is a bunch of nonsense. Like I had streamlined it into like a much tighter movie
看着罗曼在重温剧情时的表情。他就像，哦，是的，确实，那是一回事。就像，什么？我一直在经历那种感觉，当时我就想，卫星，是的，哦，天哪。是的，我忘了卫星的事了。那真的是，哦，天哪，这简直是一堆废话。我把它简化成了一部比这紧凑得多的电影，
in my memory than all this. I'm just like, that's a complete gibberish. It's a long winding parts. Here's my note for that. I wrote, the mayor learns the Soviet satellite may crash into the city, dash, and then it does question mark. I think the upshot of that is the idea that it now has opened up even more land for building on. In real life, the real Rafa Moses had to evict people. He didn't have Soviet satellites doing the job for him. This is just a stew of really truly problematic and nasty great man tropes that he's canceled
在我的记忆里。我只是觉得，那完全是胡言乱语。这是漫长而曲折的部分。这是我对此的笔记。我写道，市长得知苏联卫星可能会撞向城市，破折号，然后它真的撞了问号。我认为其结果是，它现在为建筑开发开辟了更多的土地。在现实生活中，真正的罗伯特·摩西必须驱逐居民。他没有苏联卫星帮他做这件事。这只是一锅真正令人困扰且恶心的“伟人”比喻，他被取消了……
for like 20 seconds, but he's such a genius. Obviously all that stuff that they say about him is fake and should be forgiven in the first place because he's so great or is all made up and a bunch of these me too made up nonsense is coming after him and trying to take him down. All the people are conspiring in these horrible ways and there's no notion that that Adam Driver is just wrong. You know what I mean? And also the idea of what comes,
大约20秒，但他是个天才。显然，关于他的一切说法都是假的，而且首先应该被原谅，因为他太伟大了，或者这一切都是编造的，一堆“我也是”运动编造的废话正在追着他，试图打倒他。所有的人都在以这些可怕的方式密谋，而且根本没有意识到亚当·德赖弗只是错了。你知道我的意思吗？还有关于什么的观念，
how necessary destruction is to build something. And then there's this God particle that fixes everything so that no one has to have like actually hard thought and compromise. And it's just, it's just, it's just, it's just bad stuff. I mean, this is real, like, like 13, 14 year old, like, I can't believe an old man wrote this. You know what I mean? Like, this is like, this is what- Yeah yeah it feels like something made by somebody very young or
为了建造某样东西，破坏是多么必要。然后还有这个“上帝粒子”修复了一切，这样就没人需要进行真正艰难的思考和妥协了。这简直是，简直是，简直是，简直是糟糕透顶。我的意思是，这真的很像，像13、14岁的人写的，我不敢相信一个老人写了这个。你知道我的意思吗？就像，这是什么——是的，是的，感觉就像是某个非常年轻的人或者……
very old I feel like I believe in either a very young man or a very old man yeah I guess very stoned man which apparently was old man Gary old man it uh it feels a lot like Gary old man and a Gary, Gary Old Banana, Gary Old Banana. Gary Old Bananas? It feels like somebody was like... I know what you're singing. Somebody was like, I want to like, Coppola's like, I want to make a movie about city planning. And then he got high and read like one Yoderowski Metabaron's book.
非常老的人做的，我觉得我宁愿相信是一个非常年轻的人或者一个非常老的人，是的，我猜是一个非常嗨的人，显然是老家伙加里·奥德曼，它……感觉很像加里·奥德曼，加里，加里·老香蕉，加里·老香蕉。加里·老香蕉？感觉就像有人……我知道你在唱什么。有人就像，我想，科波拉就像，我想拍一部关于城市规划的电影。然后他吸嗨了，读了一本佐杜洛夫斯基的《梅塔巴隆》。
And he's like, I'm going to do like this. Yeah, it kind of feels like he's like, should I read the Power Broker or the Ink Call? I'll read them both, I'll just alternate pages. Exactly. Okay. So wait, I wanted to ask you guys, so this next part, I want to, so Stuart, summarize it and then I've got a question for everybody, okay? Because I just want to let you know I have a question about...
然后他说，我要这样做。是的，感觉他就像，我是该读《权力掮客》还是《墨水瓶》？我两本都读，我只是交替读页面。完全正确。好吧。等等，我想问你们，所以接下来这一部分，我想，所以斯图尔特，总结一下，然后我有一个问题要问大家，好吗？因为我只是想让你们知道我有一个关于……
I was just talking about Wild Platinum and Claudio scheming to take over the bank. They do it over sex and then Crassus collapses. A sex meeting. Yeah. I'd like two it over sex, and then Crassus collapses. I'd like two eggs over sex, please. Yeah, yeah, my Google calendar says sex meeting at 10 o'clock. Okay, so then Crassus collapses. He seems to have what, like a stroke? He has a heart attack or a stroke, yeah.
我刚才在谈论狂野铂金和克劳迪奥密谋接管银行。他们通过性爱完成了这件事，然后克拉苏崩溃了。一场性爱会议。是的。我想要两个煎蛋加性爱，谢谢。是的，是的，我的谷歌日历上写着10点有性爱会议。好吧，然后克拉苏崩溃了。他似乎得了什么，比如中风？他心脏病发作或中风了，是的。
He collapses, leaving Wow and Claudio in charge. Now, then it seems like spring comes, you see flowers blooming, and Catalina and Julia get married in their car. Laurence Fishburne sits in the driver's seat, and they sit in the back. Not Adam's driver's seat, but the driver's seat of the car. Thank you, yeah. And marries them.
他崩溃了，留下哇和克劳迪奥负责。现在，然后似乎春天来了，你看到花儿盛开，卡塔利娜和朱莉娅在他们的车里结婚。劳伦斯·菲什伯恩坐在驾驶座上，他们坐在后面。不是亚当的驾驶座，而是车的驾驶座。谢谢，是的。并为他们主持婚礼。
And then there is a montage of December holidays in this kind of Abel Gans's Napoleon triple screen thing. And suddenly it's winter again. And I was like, did I hallucinate that it was spring and now it's winter again? I don't know what. And it can't be the next year because the baby is just the same age as when they got married.
然后是一段十二月假日的蒙太奇，这种阿贝尔·冈斯的《拿破仑》三屏风格。突然又是冬天了。我就想，我是不是产生了幻觉，以为是春天，现在又是冬天了？我不知道是什么。而且不可能是下一年，因为婴儿和他们结婚时是一样大的。
But let's explain. Did you guys have any sense of why there's suddenly a montage of winter holidays? I would have to remember. I also have to ask, Elliot, my notes, Let's explain. Do you guys have any sense of why there's suddenly a montage of winter holidays? I would have to remember. I also have to ask, Elliot, my notes, I just wrote down Elvis. What does that mean? Yes.
但让我们解释一下。你们有没有感觉到为什么突然出现了一段冬日假日的蒙太奇？我得回想一下。我还得问，埃利奥特，我的笔记，让我们解释一下。你们有没有感觉到为什么突然出现了一段冬日假日的蒙太奇？我得回想一下。我还得问，埃利奥特，我的笔记，我只写下了“猫王”。那是什么意思？是的。
So an Elvis impersonator is out on the street singing America the Beautiful. I think as part of Claudio's like pandering to the masses, I'm not sure. Maybe it's a busker and it's a statement about the plastic artificiality of American values. Yeah, that happens. I'm not quite sure. I love this new bit Stuart deciphered his notes by the way. Jesus Christ, what did I write?
所以一个猫王模仿者在街上唱着《美丽的亚美利加》。我认为这是克劳迪奥迎合大众的一部分，我不确定。也许是个街头艺人，这是对美国价值观虚假塑料感的一种声明。是的，确实发生了。我不太确定。我喜欢这个新片段，顺便说一句，斯图尔特破译了他的笔记。天哪，我写了什么？
Yeah, I don't know what's going on with that. I mean, I did write winter holiday montage in my notes. Yeah, that happens. So around now- And it goes on for a while. It goes on for a while that we're watching people opening presents, people spinning dreidels, people celebrating Ramadan.
是的，我不知道那是什么情况。我的意思是，我确实在笔记里写了“冬日假日蒙太奇”。是的，确实发生了。所以大约现在——而且持续了很长时间。我们看着人们拆礼物，人们转陀螺，人们庆祝斋月，这持续了很长时间。
Yeah, everybody's representing, I love it. Well, I mean, three religions. Now the city is inflamed with riots. The masses are rioting against the mayor, inflamed by Claudio, of course. The mayor's family has to escape through a secret train car tunnel. Yep, they go through the antique subway car tunnels that have been closed off for years in the city.
是的，每个人都在代表，我喜欢。好吧，我的意思是，三种宗教。现在城市里暴乱四起。群众正在反抗市长，当然是被克劳迪奥煽动的。市长的家人必须通过一条秘密火车隧道逃生。是的，他们穿过了城市里多年来一直关闭的古董地铁车厢隧道。
You know, there's that, it looked like, I think it was the subway station that is beneath City Hall that has been closed ever since September 11th. I mean, it's not been in use for a long time, but it was closed to tours and things after September 11th. I think that it looked like that in use for a long time, but it was closed to tours and things after September 11th. I think that it looked like that place. I wonder if they shot it there. It's possible. This is around when Wow Platinum and Claudio are celebrating their good fortune. They have successfully taken out their rivals.
你知道，那个，看起来，我想是市政厅下方自9月11日以来一直关闭的地铁站。我的意思是，它已经很久没用了，但在9月11日之后就关闭了参观和类似的事情。我想它看起来像那个地方。我想知道他们是不是在那里拍的。有可能。这大约是哇·铂金和克劳迪奥庆祝他们好运的时候。他们成功除掉了竞争对手。
Nothing bad could ever happen to them. And they wander into the bedroom of Hamilton Crassus III. You know the old saying, Pride goeth before more success. The old aphorism, yeah. So they go into Hamilton Crassus' bedroom, and something, it seems like he's pitching a little tent. This is, so this is, so I want to get Roman's take on this. This is by far the best, I saw this movie in a theater,
没有什么坏事会发生在他们身上。他们走进了汉密尔顿·克拉苏三世的卧室。你知道那句老话，骄傲自大先于更多的成功。那句古老的格言，是的。所以他们走进汉密尔顿·克拉苏的卧室，有些事情，看起来他支起了一个小帐篷。这是，所以这是，所以我想听听罗曼对此的看法。这是迄今为止最好的，我在电影院看了这部电影，
it was just me and four other people, not strangers, not people I knew, they were watching the movie stone-faced, very serious, and when this line came out, I laughed so loud, and nobody else in the audience reacted, and I did not regret it at all. And so, does anyone want to say what... Well, Elliot had been like, John Voight has the best line of the movie,
只有我和其他四个人，不是陌生人，不是我认识的人，他们面无表情地看着电影，非常严肃，当这句台词出来时，我笑得很大声，观众席里没有其他人有反应，我一点也不后悔。所以，有人想说……好吧，埃利奥特之前说，乔恩·沃伊特有全片最好的台词，
and the whole time, like, did I miss it? Was it one of those? Like, was it just a line that is silly because Elliot's smarter than me? Well I haven't told us all about that but let's get Roman's... Well I have to be refreshed to the exact line. I remember the moment. I'm not quoting it direct. I mean I'm trying to quote it. I can quote it direct. Oh yeah so this you wrote down in your notes.
整个过程中，就像，我错过了吗？是其中之一吗？就像，那只是一句愚蠢的台词，因为埃利奥特比我聪明？好吧，我还没告诉我们所有人，但让我们听听罗曼的……好吧，我得被提醒一下确切的台词。我记得那一刻。我不是直接引用。我的意思是，我正在尝试引用。我可以直接引用。哦，是的，所以你把这个写在你的笔记里了。
So turning to his son and wife he says, what do you think of this boner I got? Then he reveals what the boner is. It's a crossbow. It's so funny. He whips the blanket over and he's got a crossbow and it's like, it's so, this is this whole movie, if the whole movie had been at this level, I would have been like, yes, a thousand percent, you know, the last thing I expected was him to say, hey, what do you think of this bon, I would have been like, yes, a thousand percent. You know, but the last thing I expected was him to say, hey, what do you think of this boner I got?
所以转向他的儿子和妻子，他说，你们觉得我这个硬起来的东西怎么样？然后他揭示了那个硬起来的东西是什么。是一把弩。太搞笑了。他掀开毯子，他拿着一把弩，这太，整部电影，如果整部电影都是这个水平，我会说，是的，百分之一千，你知道，我最后预料到的是他说，嘿，你们觉得我这个硬起来的东西怎么样？
Seemingly, totally sincere. You don't know it's a trap at that moment. And I was like, this movie, I can't, I can't guess. And they're so shocked, he shoots wow and kills her. And then he shoots Claudio and hits him in the ass. And Claudio manages to escape, only to eventually be beaten up by his own mob. Well, we'll get back to, of course,
看起来，完全真诚。那一刻你不知道这是一个陷阱。我就想，这部电影，我不能，我不能猜。他们太震惊了，他射杀了哇并杀死了她。然后他射击克劳迪奥，击中了他的屁股。克劳迪奥设法逃脱，结果最终被他自己的暴徒殴打。好吧，我们当然会回到，
the most important thing, Roman's reaction again, in a moment. To John Boyd's boner, yeah. Or alleged boner. He, interesting thing to me is, this is a world where guns exist, because we saw Adam Driver get shot in the head. So he made a real choice,
最重要的事情，罗曼的反应，稍后。对乔恩·沃伊特的硬物，是的。或者所谓的硬物。他，对我来说有趣的事情是，这是一个枪支存在的世界，因为我们看到亚当·德赖弗头部中弹。所以他做出了一个真正的选择，
I'm going to kill these people with a crossbow so I can do this boner bit. You know? You think a gun wouldn't have been able to make enough of a tent in the seats? I mean, he's a prideful man. No, that's true. So I think there is a...
我要用弩杀这些人，这样我就可以做这个硬物的梗。你知道吗？你认为枪不能在座位上支起足够的帐篷吗？我的意思是，他是一个骄傲的人。不，那是真的。所以我认为有一个……
The theatricality of it though is... I think it's the theatricality. I think my guess is he needed a way for Claudio to survive and escape. And an arrow to the butt is a classic slapstick way to get somebody to leave a room. But also, as we're recording this before our Caddyshack 2 flop TV episode, a movie which also includes someone getting hit in the butt with an arrow. Somebody find out on Saturday.
不过它的戏剧性是……我认为是戏剧性。我猜他需要一种方式让克劳迪奥幸存并逃脱。而屁股上中箭是一种经典的闹剧方式，让某人离开房间。但同时，正如我们在录制这期《疯狂高尔夫2》烂片电视节目之前，这部电影也包括有人屁股中箭。周六见分晓。
I mean, find out on Saturday before this episode comes out. But there's also a, I assume, I wonder if there's something he's playing off of, some either ancient thing or some story he knows that involves an arrow that he's referencing, since there's so many references in this movie to other things that are floating around in Francis Ford Coppola's head.
我的意思是，在这集播出前的周六见分晓。但还有一个，我假设，我想知道他是否在模仿什么，某种古代的东西或者他知道的涉及箭的故事，他在引用它，因为这部电影里有太多关于弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉脑海中漂浮的其他事物的引用。
Yeah, that's the problem with this movie for me. Well, one of the many problems, but I'm apparently an atypical man in that I think of the Roman Empire almost never, so I don't have the background in history that I would need to understand all of the... What about their turtle formation where they lock all their shields together?
是的，这就是这部电影对我来说的问题。好吧，众多问题之一，但我显然是一个非典型的男人，因为我几乎从不思考罗马帝国，所以我没有理解所有……所需的历史背景。那他们的龟甲阵呢，他们把所有的盾牌锁在一起？
You don't ever think about that? I'm thinking about it now. It's pretty cool, they look like a turtle, but with spears. Dan, how often do you think about the Civil War? Because that's the other thing I feel like American men think about it now. They look like a turtle but with spears. Dan, how often do you think about the Civil War? Because that's the other thing I feel like American men think about a lot. Rarely. I think about...
你从来没想过吗？我现在正在想。这很酷，他们看起来像一只乌龟，但拿着长矛。丹，你多久想一次内战？因为那是美国男人经常想的另一件事。他们看起来像一只乌龟但拿着长矛。丹，你多久想一次内战？因为那是美国男人经常想的另一件事。很少。我想的是……
Do you think about ghoulies going to college a lot? Oh, ghoulies go to college. So that's your Roman Empire. Movies about small monsters. Ghoulies and gremlins and munchies. Yeah, Frankie Freeko. Available on VOD right now. Some stealth marketing for Frankie Freeko right there.
你经常想“小魔怪”上大学吗？哦，小魔怪上大学。所以那是你的罗马帝国。关于小怪物的电影。小魔怪、小精灵和小怪物。是的，弗兰基·弗里科。现在可以在VOD上观看。那里有一些弗兰基·弗里科的隐形营销。
Featuring the voices of the floppy. It was pretty open. To answer your question, Elliot, when this happened in the movie theater, it was when Audrey Plaza got shot, actually, where I was like, I was like, ho! I was like, all right! You know, like something's happening. Like, I was like, I was like, oh, I was like, all right, you know, like something's happening. Like I was kind of delighted, but it was like,
由软盘配音。这很开放。回答你的问题，埃利奥特，当这在电影院发生时，是奥黛丽·普拉扎中弹的时候，实际上，当时我就想，我就想，吼！我就想，好吧！你知道，就像发生了什么事一样。就像我当时想，哦，我就想，好吧，你知道，就像发生了什么事一样。就像我有点高兴，但就像，
it was the real classic, just this was so different and shocking. I mean, the, you know, when Caesar got shot in the face, that was a little shocking because it had a real pop sound like a Godfather movie pop, you know, like a real, like I was like, oh, I remember that guy. I like that guy's movies, you know? Yeah.
这是真正的经典，这太不同且令人震惊了。我的意思是，你知道，当凯撒脸部中弹时，那有点令人震惊，因为它有一种真正的爆裂声，就像《教父》电影里的爆裂声，你知道，就像真正的，就像我当时想，哦，我记得那个人。我喜欢那个人的电影，你知道吗？是的。
I mean, the guy who directed maybe the greatest person being shot in the head scene in any movie ever made, you know, that whole sequence. Totally. But the, but And then the second greatest guy being shot in the head moment when Mo Green gets killed the best at the end of the same movie, he's really good at shooting people on faces. And he was kind of wasted in this movie to tell you the truth. But that was a moment of delight just because of the shocking violence.
我的意思是，那个导演了也许是有史以来任何电影中最伟大的头部中弹场景的人，你知道，整个序列。完全同意。但是，然后是第二个最伟大的头部中弹时刻，当莫·格林在同一部电影结尾被杀时，他真的很擅长射击人们的脸。说实话，他在电影里有点被浪费了。但那一刻的喜悦仅仅是因为那令人震惊的暴力。
I had no idea that that was what was about to happen. So it was kind of like, all right, this thing's a lot. But him talking about his boner just left you cold. Well, no, I mean, I think the boner part was like, calm it. It really happens kind of all at once. There's not a lot of time in between, so I didn't have processing time. Yeah, I was taking a big slurp of my soda
我根本不知道会发生什么。所以这有点像，好吧，这东西太猛了。但他谈论他的硬物只是让你感到冷场。好吧，不，我的意思是，我认为硬物部分就像，冷静点。它真的几乎同时发生。中间没有太多时间，所以我没有处理时间。是的，我正在大口喝我的苏打水，
and just spit it all over everyone. Speaking of fearing missing this, I knew that there was this line, all I had heard about was this line about how John Foy had this great line, and the movie is very long. Well, it's not that long, but it feels long. It's like about two hours, little less very long. Yeah. And I- Well, it's not that long, but it feels long. It's like about two hours, a little less than 220.
然后把它喷得到处都是。说到害怕错过这个，我知道有这句台词，我所听到的只是关于乔恩·沃伊特有这句伟大的台词，而且电影很长。好吧，没那么长，但感觉很长。大约两个小时，没那么长。是的。而且我——好吧，没那么长，但感觉很长。大约两个小时，不到220分钟。
Yeah, okay. It's longer than, to my mind, the ideal length of a movie, which is less than two hours. It's longer than the first movies. It's longer. The important thing is it's longer than my bladder can stand. So all through this movie, I was like, I gotta wait out for this John Voight line.
是的，好吧。在我看来，它比电影的理想长度要长，也就是不到两个小时。它比第一部电影长。它更长。重要的是它比我的膀胱能承受的时间要长。所以整部电影我都在想，我得等这句乔恩·沃伊特的台词。
And then I finally, I'm in physical pain. I have to leave the theater. Were you pinching it with your fingers? It's not, no. You were literally pinching your urethra shut with your fingers? Yeah, I was pinching my urethra shut. Like you're trying to control a fire hose?
然后我终于，我感到身体上的痛苦。我必须离开电影院。你用手指捏着它吗？不是，不。你真的用手指捏着尿道吗？是的，我捏着尿道。就像你在试图控制消防水带一样？
I had to pee so badly. I was hurting. Roman is really rethinking dropping this into a 99 BIP. I thought to myself, surely, surely it will not happen at this exact moment. If I run to the restroom, I will not miss this iconic line. And of course, it is exactly when this happens. And then you came back and the audience was rolling on the floor like... Well, I mean, fortunately.
我尿急得厉害。我很痛。罗曼真的在重新考虑把它放进99 BIP里。我心想，肯定，肯定不会就在这一刻发生。如果我跑去洗手间，我就不会错过这句标志性的台词。当然，这正是发生的时候。然后你回来，观众们在地上打滚，就像……好吧，我的意思是，幸运的是。
They were cheering, firing guns into the air, singing all that side, yeah. So I looked up the line and fortunately, you know, someone had put most of the scene on TikTok, not the Boner line. Like, I saw the rest of the scene that I had missed. Leaving a lot of gold on the table. Well then in the description it was like,
他们欢呼雀跃，向空中开枪，唱着那首歌，是的。所以我查了那句台词，幸运的是，你知道，有人把大部分场景放到了TikTok上，不是硬物那句。就像，我看到了我错过的场景的其余部分。留下了很多金子没用。好吧，然后在描述里就像，
like dude, right before before this the guy said this line about his boner. Because apparently like they whipped out their phone they're like oh man I missed the key point but something else crazy has got to happen with this setup. You know? Because the other thing is it's not like it's an it's not a funny line in and of itself. What is funny is that it is appearing in this otherwise serious-minded allegorical movie said by John Voight in a scene near what you have to assume is the climax of the film.
就像伙计，就在这之前，这家伙说了这句关于他硬物的台词。因为显然，他们掏出手机，就像，哦天哪，我错过了关键点，但这个设置肯定还有其他疯狂的事情发生。你知道吗？因为另一件事是，它本身并不是一句有趣的台词。有趣的是，它出现在这部原本严肃的寓言电影中，由乔恩·沃伊特在电影高潮附近的一个场景中说出。
It is such a, it's such a, it's, there's something about how it is the least eloquent thing I think a character has said in any movie I've seen in years. Yeah. Yeah. What a performance. Okay, so as we said, Crassus gets his revenge. The riots are running wild around New Rome. Caesar appears as like a hologram or something,
这真是，这真是，这真是，这有什么东西，这是我认为多年来我在任何电影中听到的角色说出的最不文雅的话。是的。是的。多么精彩的表演。好吧，正如我们所说，克拉苏得到了他的复仇。暴乱在纽约城周围肆虐。凯撒像全息图一样出现，
and he gives a speech talking about like time and things like that, and calms everybody down, and like shows visions of his utopia. Is that correct? Is that what happened? Yes, this scene, so this is the classic, the man of genius comes out and he gives a speech that enthralls the crowd and calms their passions and wins them to side, and the speech he gives is so, it's just such vaporware.
他发表了一场演讲，谈论时间之类的事情，让每个人都冷静下来，并展示了他乌托邦的愿景。这是正确的吗？这就是发生的事情吗？是的，这个场景，所以这是经典的，天才人物走出来，发表了一场演讲，迷住了人群，平息了他们的激情，赢得了他们的支持，而他发表的演讲是如此，简直是虚无缥缈。
It's such empty conceptual nonsense. And it does not speak to any of the actual needs that these people have shown up to this point and why they're reacting. It's like, say what you will about Donald Trump, the terrible, terrible person, just an evil bad man. But when he speaks, he is directly reacting to the needs he feels in the audience members
这简直是空洞的概念废话。它并没有触及这些人到目前为止所表现出的任何实际需求，以及他们为什么会有这种反应。这就像，不管你怎么评价唐纳德·特朗普，那个可怕的、可怕的人，只是一个邪恶的坏人。但当他说话时，他是在直接回应他在观众中感受到的需求，
that he is talking to, the ones he wants to appeal to. Whereas Adam Driver, when he's giving the speech, I'm like, I don't even know. I don't know who you're winning over with what with this. And so to see the audience kind of, the crowd be like, you're right, you're right. What a true leader.
他正在交谈的那些人，他想吸引的人。而亚当·德赖弗，当他发表演讲时，我就想，我甚至不知道。我不知道你用这个赢得了谁的支持。所以看到观众那种，人群就像，你是对的，你是对的。多么伟大的领袖。
Yay, platitudes, yeah. As an audience member in the theater, I was like, I don't understand what he's saying. This doesn't mean anything to me. And this is another part where I'm just like so I'm so out with this movie Where it's like where it's like it really tries to have it both ways like it It has great contempt for almost all the rich people which is fine Like you can hate all the rich people all you want the job creators from a crisis Totally sucks and all the rich people all you want. The job creators from it? Crassus totally sucks and all the Crassus family sucks.
耶，陈词滥调，是的。作为电影院的观众，我当时想，我不明白他在说什么。这对我来说没有任何意义。这是另一个让我觉得，我完全无法接受这部电影的地方，它就像，它真的试图两头兼顾，就像它对几乎所有的富人都怀有极大的蔑视，这很好，就像你可以尽情讨厌所有的富人，来自克拉苏的就业创造者，完全烂透了，你可以尽情讨厌所有的富人。克拉苏完全烂透了，克拉苏家族也烂透了。
Obviously it has this exception for for Caesar because it was sort of genius. And what it rests on is this idea that you have to serve the people, give the people what they need, but it has complete contempt for the people. They're just this dumb mass of people that follow Claudio or they're this dumb mass of people that are just like wooed by nonsense language. I mean, there's no actual common people represented at all in the movie. Yeah, there's no, the only characters we see who come close to being actual on the ground people are that one guy who plays the tuba in the marching band in that one scene and the kid who shoots Caesar in the face, I guess.
显然它对凯撒有这个例外，因为他某种程度上是天才。它所基于的是这种观念，即你必须服务于人民，给人民他们所需要的，但它对人民怀有完全的蔑视。他们只是一群愚蠢的群众，跟随克劳迪奥，或者他们是一群被无意义的语言所吸引的愚蠢群众。我的意思是，电影中根本没有表现出任何真正的普通人。是的，没有，我们看到的唯一接近真实地面上的人的角色是那个在那个场景中在行进乐队里吹大号的家伙，以及那个朝凯撒脸上开枪的孩子，我想。
But you're right, there's no ordinary citizen point of view ever presented in this, a movie where you have to assume hundreds, if not thousands of people are killed by a falling satellite that devastates the city. And that is, and that's like, I just watched Life Force recently, and that's a movie about a nude space just watched Life Force recently. And that's a movie that, about a, about a space vampire, about a nude space vampire that sucks the life out of people.
但你是对的，这里从来没有呈现出普通公民的观点，这是一部你必须假设成百上千人被一颗摧毁城市的坠落卫星杀死的电影。而且那是，而且那是，我最近刚看了《生命力》，那是一部关于裸体太空……我最近刚看了《生命力》。那是一部关于，关于太空吸血鬼，关于吸食人们生命的裸体太空吸血鬼的电影。
And that showed more, more feeling for the ordinary everyday English person than this movie shows for the people of New Rome, you know. It's ostensible ideas are about like serving people in the public and how to make a society. And society is completely unrepresented in any realistic or meaningful way. They're all just, they're all really just pawns who are like dumbasses who follow
它表现出的对普通英国人的感情比这部电影对纽约城人民表现出的感情还要多，你知道。它表面的想法是关于服务公众和如何建立社会。而社会在任何现实或有意义的方式中都没有得到表现。他们都只是，他们真的只是棋子，就像跟随克劳迪奥的笨蛋，或者被无意义语言所吸引的笨蛋。这简直是，这很奇怪。就像我完全明白。你可以有关于国王之类的莎士比亚戏剧。你知道，那很好。就像你不需要在每部媒体喜剧中都表现出平民。悲剧里有国王之类的。我拼命想把哪个莎士比亚标题变成关于另一个词的谐音，但它只是……
Claudio or sort of dumbasses that are wooed by nonsense language. It's just like, it's weird. Like I totally get that. You can have Shakespeare plays that are all about kings and shit. You know, that's fine. Like you don't need the commoner has to be represented in every comedy of media. The tragedies and there is kings and shit. I'm so desperately trying to think of what Shakespeare title I can turn into a pun about another word for shit. But it's just, it's...
《哈姆雷特》？不，那行不通。什么？我说“国王涂抹”。国王涂抹。那效果很好。是的，是的。《厕所与克瑞西达》？
The emulet? No, that doesn't work. What? I said king smear. King smear. That works pretty well. Yeah, yeah. Toilets and Cressida?
那行得通吗？是的。为什么我们。厕所与克瑞西达？那是对的吗？为什么我们走上了这条路，在所有的路中？好吧，说到路，所以凯撒承诺了这些神奇的漂浮发光长袍，就像《超级马里奥》里的彩虹路。克劳迪奥的暴徒反过来对付他。克拉苏被凯撒愿景的荣耀所折服，所以他把所有的财富都留给了凯撒·卡塔利娜。所以这将使他能够建立这个乌托邦。西塞罗市长和他的家人加入了凯撒的航行。他们站在那座发光的桥上。
Does that work? Yeah. Why did we. Toilets and Cressida? Is that right? Why did we go down this road of all the roads? Okay, speaking of roads, so Caesar promises these magical floating glowing robes that are all like the Rainbow Road in Super Mario. Claudio's mob turns on him. Crassus is overcome by the glory of Caesar's vision, so he leaves all of his riches to Caesar Catalina. So that's going to allow him to build this utopia. Mayor Cicero and his family join Caesar on this voyage. They stand upon this glowing bridge.
人们都非常兴奋。他们在庆祝。他设法让除了小婴儿凯撒、朱利安·凯撒的婴儿之外的所有人时间停止。让我们说这是一个看起来非常奇怪的镜头。这是从下方拍摄的。他们都像站在玻璃上之类的，他们正透过它拍摄。
People are all very excited. They're celebrating. And he manages to stop time for everyone except for little baby Caesar, Julian Caesar's baby. And let's say that this is a very strange looking shot too. This is shot from below. They're all like standing on glass or something and they're shooting through it.
他们身后有绿幕。这也是，这是一个令人不安的时刻。我认为这应该是一个充满希望的时刻，就像这种存在于时间之外并成为创造性天才的能力现在也在他们的孩子身上，但这就像时间停止了，除了这个婴儿。谁来喂这个婴儿？
And there's like green screen behind them. This is also, this is such an upsetting moment. I think it's supposed to be a moment of like, hope for the future, like this ability to exist outside of time and be a creative genius is now in their child as well, but it's like time has stopped, except for this baby. Who's going to feed this baby?
就像谁来让时间恢复？自从《皮囊之下》以来，我还没有对一个在我面前被遗弃的银幕上的孩子如此担心。但婴儿是那个停止时间的人，对吧？也许吧。一定是，因为其他人被冻结了。因为她是那个在移动的人，每个人。但我以为她，但我以为，朱利叶斯不是告诉凯撒停止时间吗？也许我记错了。我不知道。但他们被冻结了。我的意思是，我想她是这样做的，但这并没有真正……是婴儿没有……好吧，婴儿不知道她在做什么。
Like who's going to unstop time? Not since under the skin have I been more worried about an on-screen child who's being abandoned in front of me. But the baby is the one stopping time right? Maybe. It must be because the others are frozen. Because she's the one's moving and everyone. But I thought she, but I thought, doesn't Julius hate to tell Caesar to stop time? Maybe I'm maybe I'm misremembering it. I don't know. But then they're frozen. Like I mean I think she does, but it doesn't really make... It's the baby that doesn't... Well, the baby doesn't know what she's doing.
这让我非常不安。这是一个非常令人不安的电影结局方式。我得到的感觉是，他们正在为下一代留下未来。为了续集，《大都市2：婴儿都市》。我的笔记然后写道，宣誓效忠。这之后发生了什么吗？有没有像演讲之类的东西？有一张标题卡，我想那是孩子们读的旁白。是的。哦，是的。
It's very upsetting to me. It's a very upsetting way to end the movie. The feeling I get is that they're leaving the future for the next generation. For the sequel, Megalopolis 2, Babyopolis. My notes then say, pledge allegiance. Did something happen after this? Was there like a speech or something? There's a title card, and I think it's the narration read by children. Yes. Oh yeah.
就像我们宣誓效忠人类之类的。我把它拉到我面前，因为我想确保我们有它。它意义重大。你把它打印出来并塑封了。你把它贴在墙上。我宣誓效忠我们的人类大家庭以及我们保护的所有物种。一个地球，不可分割，长寿，教育，人人平等，这就是孩子们说的。
And it's like we pledge allegiance like to the human race or something like that. I pulled this up in front of me because I wanted to make sure we had it. It meant so much. You printed it out and laminated it. You put it up on the wall. I pledge allegiance to our human family and to all the species that we protect. One earth, indivisible, with long life, education, and justice for all, is what the kids say.
所以把它贴在下次选举前你家门前的标语牌上，这房子的价值观，是的。看，问题在于它出现在《大都市》的结尾。我确实喜欢那种不是民族主义的宣誓，就像对我们宣誓。我们都可以支持人类的价值观，每个人都能获得正义和教育。
So stick that on a placard in front of your house for the next election, the values in this house, yeah. Look, the problem with that is that it comes at the end of Megalopolis. I do like the idea of a pledge that is not a nationalistic sort of just like pledge to us. We can all stand behind the values of the human race and everybody getting justice and education.
它不适合这部电影，这部电影是关于什么的。不，不，电影真的不适合。这是一部真正的罗伯特·摩西观点的电影，就像人民不知道他们想要什么。人民是羊。他们必须由天才向他们展示什么是对他们最好的。而且有人需要做出决定。这是一部我认为制作它的人认为他们正在制作一部支持民主、支持平等正义的电影，但他们本质上在很多方面制作了一部法西斯电影，因为有一个人理解，他需要控制，你不应该质疑他，
It doesn't fit with this movie, which this movie is about. No, no, the movie doesn't really. It's a real Robert Moses viewpoint movie where it's like the people don't know what they want. The people are sheep. They have to be shown by a genius what is best for them. And someone needs to make the decision. It is a movie that I think is the person making it thinks they're making a pro democracy, pro equality justice movie, but they are making a essentially in many ways a fascist movie about because there is one man who understands and he needs to take control and you should not question him
无论他做什么。我只是，也许我只是生气，因为我意识到我应该说《厕所安德洛尼克斯》，因为《厕所与克瑞西达》是一首诗，对吧？就像它不是一部戏剧。所以。不，《厕所与克瑞西达》是一部戏剧。它是一部戏剧吗？
and no matter what he does. And I'm just, and maybe I'm just mad because I realized I should have said Toilets Andronicus because Toilets And Crested is a poem, right? Like it's not a play. So. No, Toilets And Crested is a play. Is it a play?
我在想什么？那他的史诗是什么？我不知道。我对这种诗歌不太熟悉。莎士比亚，如果你在听，写信告诉我们你想在哪个剧里放一个厕所。我们在这个播客上有两个英语专业的学生。是的，我的意思是，我们正在进入最终审判的领域，但这部电影有很多引人注目的地方。其中一些部分某种程度上让我……
What am I thinking? What's his epic poem then? I don't know. I am less familiar with this poetry. Shakespeare, if you're listening, write in and tell us which play you want to have a toilet in. We had two English majors on this podcast. Yeah, I mean we're getting into the final judgement sort of area, but there's much that is striking about this movie. There are parts of it that sort of took me
某种程度上不顾我自己，但你是对的。伙计们，《厕所与克瑞西达》，我想到的是乔叟的诗，然后莎士比亚都以此为基础。那是对的，是的，是的。所以《厕所与克瑞西达》是……谢谢，谢谢。好吧，让我修改一下记分牌。好吧，拿出来。
sort of in spite of myself, but you're right. Guys, Toilets and Cressida, I was thinking of the poem by Chaucer and then Shakespeare both play on it. That's right, yeah, yeah. So Toilets and Cressida were... Thank you, thank you. Okay, let me just amend the scoreboard. Okay, get it out.
经过进一步审查，针对《厕所与克瑞西达》的判罚已被推翻。经过进一步审查，针对《厕所与克瑞西达》的判罚已被推翻。你为我结晶了一些东西，埃利奥特。这部电影作为一种声明，对我来说唯一有意义的解读方式是弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉就像，天才很好，高于所有人，
On further review, the call against Toilets and Cressida has been overturned. On further review, the call against Toyotso Cressida has been overturned. You've crystallized something for me, Elliot. The only thing that makes sense to me about this movie as a statement, the only way I can read this is Francis Ford Coppola being like, geniuses are good and above everyone
他们不应该被质疑，也许我就是其中之一。因为在政治上，它到处都是，没有任何意义。它没有提出任何特定的可理解的哲学。它只是一堆发生的事情。所以与其说是寓言，不如说是一堆《大都市》，一堆发生的事情。所以与其说是寓言，不如说是一堆，《大都市》，一堆发生的事情。这简直就像每本《狗人》书里的第五章，叫第五章，
and they shouldn't be questioned and maybe I'm one Because Politically it's all over the place doesn't make any sense. It's not staking out any particular Understandable philosophy. It's just a bunch of stuff that happened So instead of a fable it should say a bunch of Megalopolis a bunch of stuff that happened. So instead of a fable, it should say a bunch of, Megalopolis, a bunch of stuff that happened. Which is literally like the fifth chapter in every Dog Man book is called Chapter Five,
一堆发生的事情，接下来发生的一堆事情。所以也许弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉应该拍那部《狗人》电影。斯图尔特，你怎么看？《狗人》，是的，我觉得他应该拍那部电影。那是，那些是家伙，玩家，你可以在裂缝中扮演的角色种族吗？
a bunch of stuff that happened, a bunch of stuff that happened next. So maybe Fransfjord Coppola should have made that Dog Man movie. Stuart, what do you think? Dog Man, yeah, I think he should have made that movie. Is that where, are those the guy, the player, character race you can play in rifts
发生了一堆事，接着又发生了一堆事。所以也许弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉应该去拍那部《神探狗狗》电影。斯图尔特，你觉得呢？《神探狗狗》，是的，我觉得他应该拍那部电影。那是，那些家伙，玩家，你在《裂界》里能玩的角色种族吗？
that have the body of a human but like the head and some of the traits of a dog? Is that Dogman? That's kind of like a sinusophilic or canosophilic. That's the kind of thing you see sometimes in Old Tales of the Saints. Some of them have dog heads. But no, that's not what dog... Dogman is about a... He's a police officer with a dog's head.
拥有人类的身体，但长着狗的头和一些狗的特征？那是“狗人”（Dogman）吗？那有点像某种犬头人或犬科崇拜。你在一些关于圣徒的古老传说中偶尔会看到这种东西。他们中的一些人长着狗头。但不对，那不是……“狗人”讲的是一个……他是一个长着狗头的警察。
Oh, that's too bad. And it's a best-selling book of, a series of books for children. We should get into our final judgments, but before we do, I just wanna give... Oh, I thought we had started already. I wanna give Stuart some plaudits for how he handled that. That's cool, anyone else wanna give me plaudits?
哦，那太糟糕了。而且那是一套畅销的儿童系列读物。我们应该进入最终评价环节了，但在开始之前，我只想给……哦，我以为我们已经开始了。我想给斯图尔特（Stuart）一些赞美，表扬他处理这件事的方式。太酷了，还有人想给我一些赞美吗？
Earlier. Yeah, I'll give you all the plaudits. No, I just, you know, I was keeping an eye on time and early on I'm like, oh man, we're never, this is gonna be a four-hour episode but Stuart you you got us through The trick is forgetting things like satellites falling on yeah But of course this is where we give our final judgments whether we thought that Michaelopoulos was a good bad movie a bad movie, or a movie we kind of liked. Is it a movie where you get some joy out of its badness,
早些时候。是的，我会给你所有的赞美。不，我只是，你知道，我一直在留意时间，早些时候我就想，天哪，我们永远也……这会变成一期四个小时的节目，但斯图尔特，你带我们完成了。诀窍在于忘记像卫星坠落之类的事情，是的。但当然，现在是我们给出最终评价的时候了，评价我们认为《大都会》（Megalopolis）是一部“好坏参半”的电影、一部烂片，还是我们有点喜欢的电影。这是一部你能从它的糟糕中获得乐趣的电影吗，
no joy to be found in Mudville, or did we actually like it a bit? I am gonna say good bad in the sense that you so rarely get something this personal and big. Like I kind of, in a weird way, didn't know whether we should do this at first, like until, you know, like we got so many people, you gotta do Megalopolis,
在“泥潭镇”（Mudville）找不到任何乐趣，还是我们其实有点喜欢它？我会说它是“好坏参半”，因为你很少能看到如此个人化且宏大的作品。就像我，以一种奇怪的方式，起初不知道我们是否应该做这一期，直到，你知道，我们收到了很多人的要求，说你必须做《大都会》，
I wanna hear what you say about Megalopolis. But part of me was like, well, I don't wanna like take someone down for like, a passion. I don't wanna give the masses what they want, I'm a genius, I know better than they do. Well, I feel bad about like taking like, for like a passion. You wanna give the masses what they want? I'm a genius, I know better than they do. Well, I feel bad about like taking like a passion project down.
我想听听你对《大都会》的评价。但我内心的一部分觉得，好吧，我不想因为一个人的热情而打击他。我不想给大众他们想要的，我是个天才，我比他们更懂。好吧，因为一个热情项目而打击它，我感到很糟糕。你想给大众他们想要的？我是个天才，我比他们更懂。好吧，因为一个热情项目而打击它，我感到很糟糕。
Like even if it's Misbegotten, like I do appreciate the swing. I don't think that this movie is successful and there's large chunks of it that are boring but I say good bad in the sense that like I would not discourage anyone with any curiosity about curiosity about this movie from seeing this movie because it is quite an experience you know if you're interested if you're willing to commit the time yeah sure watch it because there's gonna be some stuff in it they're gonna have
即使它是个失败之作，我也欣赏这种尝试。我不认为这部电影是成功的，而且其中有很大一部分很无聊，但我说它是“好坏参半”，是因为我不会劝阻任何对这部电影有好奇心的人去看它，因为它确实是一次独特的体验。你知道，如果你感兴趣，如果你愿意投入时间，是的，当然可以看，因为里面会有一些东西让你
you grasping your head and shaking your fist to the heavens. So that's what I say. So what do you think? Yeah, I mean, I feel I have less of an issue with like targeting passion projects because I feel like passion projects often suffer from a certain amount of like great man syndrome and delusion of genius. But I don't know, I feel like this movie
抓耳挠腮，向天挥拳。这就是我的看法。那么你怎么看？是的，我的意思是，我觉得我不太介意针对热情项目，因为我觉得热情项目往往会受到某种程度的“伟人综合症”和天才妄想的影响。但我不知道，我觉得这部电影
would fall somewhere in the like between a good bad movie and almost like there's parts of it that are a movie I kind of like. I mean, it's, I feel like time is going to be kinder to this than at least current critics are. I feel like it reminds me in a lot of ways of either a Neil Breen movie or if Neil Breen had directed the Star Wars prequels because it feels a lot like those movies.
介于一部“好坏参半”的电影和一部我有点喜欢的电影之间。我的意思是，我觉得时间对它会比现在的影评人更宽容。我觉得它在很多方面让我想起了尼尔·布林（Neil Breen）的电影，或者如果尼尔·布林执导了《星球大战》前传，因为它感觉很像那些电影。
Like they're like at least it doesn't feel like mass-produced garbage, but it is still kind of like garbage. So I guess that's not a direct answer, but like, I'm glad this movie exists and I feel like if you're interested in it, you should check it out. It's a mess. I feel similar to Stuart. I think it's good bad with it. There's some things about it that I like that are enough to make it a movie I am glad to
就像它们至少感觉不像批量生产的垃圾，但它仍然有点像垃圾。所以我猜这不是一个直接的回答，但我很高兴这部电影存在，我觉得如果你对它感兴趣，你应该去看看。它是一团糟。我的感觉和斯图尔特类似。我认为它是“好坏参半”。它有一些我喜欢的地方，足以让它成为一部我很高兴
have seen, you know, even if I'm never going to watch it again probably. And I feel I think you're right that with your kids, well, eventually, eventually, Dad, can we watch Megalopolis? You're not ready yet. You wouldn't understand. Meanwhile, I'm trying to get them to watch Metropolis, another kind of politically mushy movie set in the city of the future. And they have no interest, even though it's that's a great movie.
看过的电影，你知道，即使我可能永远不会再看第二遍。而且我觉得你说得对，关于你的孩子们，好吧，最终，最终，爸爸，我们可以看《大都会》吗？你还没准备好。你不会理解的。与此同时，我正试图让他们看《大都会》（Metropolis），另一部设定在未来城市的政治上有些模糊的电影。他们毫无兴趣，尽管那是一部伟大的电影。
But they there's I think the future film critics will look back on it knowing what it is and being able to pick out the few kind of pearls that are in the morass of sludge rather than us looking at it now expecting something different than it is, which is what we're expecting is a coherent story with interesting characters. And instead, future generations will be like, well, that was a fascinating capstone to Francis Ford Coppola's career. And now we can, the same way that I just finished reading Patrick McGillian's biography, Alfred Hitchcock,
但我认为未来的影评人会回顾它，了解它是什么，并能够从那堆泥沼中挑出几颗珍珠，而不是像我们现在这样期待它与众不同，我们期待的是一个连贯的故事和有趣的角色。相反，后代会说，嗯，那是弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉职业生涯中迷人的压轴之作。现在我们可以，就像我刚读完帕特里克·麦吉利根（Patrick McGillian）写的阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克（Alfred Hitchcock）传记一样，
and in that he's able to treat Hitchcock's later movies, which at the time were considered abysmal and which are certainly not among his best. But now you can look at them and be like, here's the good things in them, here's the not so good things in them. I think it'll be kind of like that. But at the moment,
在书中，他能够对待希区柯克后期的电影，这些电影在当时被认为是糟糕透顶的，当然也不属于他最好的作品。但现在你可以审视它们并说，这里是其中的优点，这里是其中的不足。我想它会是那样的。但目前，
it's kind of nice to watch this movie now at a moment when you're, it's rare that I see a movie that has this level of production behind it and this level of artistic vision behind it where I'm like, what, like what is he doing? Like, why is he doing that? And there's, that's something I like you're saying Stuart in an era of mass produced, you know, casinos made for the people by the mayor you know that's something to be at least glad that someone's willing to put their the shares they sold in their winery where their mouth is you know.
现在看这部电影感觉还不错，因为很少能看到一部拥有这种制作水平和艺术视野的电影，让我觉得，什么，他到底在做什么？他为什么要那样做？而且，就像你说的斯图尔特，在一个批量生产的时代，你知道，由市长为人民建造的赌场，你知道，至少值得高兴的是，有人愿意把他们卖掉酒庄股份的钱投入到自己的理想中，你知道。
Roman what do you think? You loved it right? I think that you know what is it like 15 years of watching bad movies says rotted y'all's brain because this is a bad bad movie Like it's Roman I've seen things you couldn't imagine movies glittering off the shoulder of Here's the thing I think this is a bad bad movie and and I think that if you compare it to other it this is a I think this is a bad, bad movie. And I think that if you compare it to other, this is like a false premise of like, it is interesting whereas all like superhero movies
罗曼（Roman），你怎么看？你很喜欢它，对吧？我想，你知道，看了15年的烂片把你们的脑子都搞坏了，因为这是一部彻头彻尾的烂片。罗曼，我见过你们无法想象的事情，电影在……的肩头闪烁。事情是这样的，我认为这是一部彻头彻尾的烂片，而且我认为如果你把它和其他电影相比，这是一个错误的假设，即它很有趣，而所有的超级英雄电影
are boring, at least this thing exists and it has some kind of vision or whatever. But that is not what you are, what this thing is occupying space of. It is occupying the space of like, take time to stare at a loved one's face for two hours or something like that. Like literally. Roman, if that's the way you think,
都很无聊，至少这个东西存在，它有某种愿景之类的。但那不是你所说的，这个东西所占据的空间。它占据的空间就像是，花时间盯着爱人的脸看两个小时之类的。字面意思。罗曼，如果你是这么想的，
you're never gonna be able to make it in this business. I was never gonna do that, that's the thing. Literally do anything and learn a language. I meant to do. Certainly there are better ways to use the limited time you have on Earth, for sure, yeah, yeah. I mean, it's just, if it had this vision and was messy and was chaotic and whatever, but
你永远无法在这个行业立足。我从来没打算那样做，这就是重点。字面意思就是做任何事并学习一门语言。我是认真的。当然，地球上有限的时间肯定有更好的利用方式，确实，是的，是的。我的意思是，如果它有这种愿景，而且混乱、无序之类的，但
it's just like as you dig into the ideas of the movie, I think those ideas are bad and dangerous ideas. Like I think that they actually are pernicious, like that make the world a worse place. That's why I like, I kind of, I was almost wooed by this idea of like the passion project that you don't want to take on and criticize. Except for that the passion project is kind of this weird, like defensive great man genius that that this this idea of this fake populism of like caring about the people and that even the movie cares about people and serving people, but then ignores them, ignores their needs.
当你深入挖掘电影的思想时，我认为这些思想是糟糕且危险的。我觉得它们实际上是有害的，会让世界变得更糟。这就是为什么我几乎被这种“热情项目”的想法所吸引，你不想去批评它。除非这个热情项目是一种奇怪的、防御性的“伟人天才”论，这种虚假的民粹主义，比如关心人民，甚至电影也关心人民和服务人民，但随后又忽视他们，忽视他们的需求。
That there's this phony, like kind of me too crisis in the middle of this thing that's completely dashed by facts that exonerate this man. All that sort of stuff. If it was, if the underlying core of this was sort of more benign or innocuous, I would have more charity towards its big swings. But I think that it actually has terrible ideas at its core. I feel like that almost makes it more interesting to this guy.
在这部电影中间有一个虚假的、类似于“我也是”（Me Too）的危机，被证明这个男人清白的证据完全推翻了。所有这些东西。如果这背后的核心更温和或无害，我会对它的大胆尝试更宽容。但我认为它的核心实际上有可怕的思想。我觉得这反而让它对这家伙来说更有趣。
I get that. Yeah. And so like if you're like, again, if it's like... In case you're worried that this movie is going to sway people. Yeah. I mean, I don't think it is either, but I just feel like it should be held accountable for its dumbness. You know, like-
我明白了。是的。所以，如果它是……以防你担心这部电影会影响人们。是的。我的意思是，我也不认为它会，但我只是觉得它应该为它的愚蠢负责。你知道，就像——
I would argue it does, because he like spent so much of his money for a huge flop that is being publicly pillory. Yeah. Saying he owned himself. But you know, and I know this too, because we went, we're all, like I'm a little older than you guys are, but like,
我会说它确实负责了，因为他花了很多钱拍了一部巨大的烂片，现在正被公开嘲笑。是的。说他自作自受。但你知道，我也知道这一点，因为我们去了，我们都……我比你们稍微大一点，但就像，
you've watched. You look great. But, thank you. But like, you've watched like really misguided millennials in Gen Z resurrect the Star Wars prequel trilogy and talk about its secret genius. And you're like, no, you don't understand. We were there. It's fucking awful. Like you have to trust us on this.
你看过。你看上去很棒。谢谢。但就像，你看着那些被误导的千禧一代和Z世代复活了《星球大战》前传三部曲，谈论它隐藏的天才。你会说，不，你不明白。我们当时就在那儿。它烂透了。你必须相信我们。
The book is closed on that matter. And you're right. This is going to be resurrected and people are going to find things in it. And it's just going to be just, that's going to be such an irritating process to witness in 20 years. Because it truly is like of the moment, just to take it in the moment, it is dealing with these ideas of populism and politics and greatness and being sort of great men, being sort of somehow thwarted in their great...
这件事已经盖棺定论了。你是对的。这部电影会被复活，人们会从中发现一些东西。20年后见证这个过程会非常令人恼火。因为它确实是当下的产物，仅仅从当下看，它正在处理这些关于民粹主义、政治、伟大以及“伟人”在某种程度上被阻碍的观念……
What's so crazy about the movie is with all this crazy stuff that happens, like, you know, everything is just given to Caesar. Like he, you know, he has this magic particle that heals his face, like the richest man in the world gives him all the money he needs to do his thing. A satellite clears the land for him to build his thing. It's just like, it is full, like this moment of like, billionaires and so-called geniuses and bad populism and pretending to serve people, like these are bad ideas to play with poorly right now.
这部电影最疯狂的地方在于，所有这些疯狂的事情发生时，比如，你知道，一切都给了凯撒。他，你知道，他有一种治愈他脸部的魔法粒子，世界上最富有的人给了他所有他需要的东西来做他的事。一颗卫星为他清理了土地来建造他的东西。这就像，它充满了这种时刻，亿万富翁、所谓的“天才”和糟糕的民粹主义，假装服务人民，这些都是现在被糟糕地玩弄的坏主意。
And that's what I think, that's the part that really like incenses me about it as a movie. You've given the passionate, swaying the masses speech that the movie fails to do. Yeah, that's fair. I'm one of the dumb masses. I want to follow this guy. Tell me about your utopia, Roman. But I want it to be so much better.
这就是我认为作为一部电影真正让我愤怒的地方。你发表了那个电影未能实现的、关于热情和动摇大众的演讲。是的，这很公平。我是愚蠢大众的一员。我想追随这个家伙。告诉我你的乌托邦，罗曼。但我希望它能好得多。
I can deal with all the nonsense of it. In fact, one of the things I think it's the most, the miracle of this movie is that I think Adam Driver at the center of this comes out pretty unscathed. Like he is, he commits to this nonsense in this way that is almost, I just don't even know how he does it. Like, you know, he sounds like he just leans into it, but he's not hammy.
我可以处理所有的胡言乱语。事实上，我认为这部电影最奇迹的一点是，我认为处于核心位置的亚当·德赖弗（Adam Driver）几乎毫发无损。他以一种几乎让我不知道他怎么做到的方式投入到这些胡言乱语中。就像，你知道，他听起来只是顺势而为，但他并不做作。
That's the part where I'm like, I liked him more coming out of this movie than I ever have, but like it just added to my esteem of him. Well, something that we see a lot in the movies on the podcast is that when you are an actor who's in a movie that doesn't make sense or is not good. You never win points by being openly disdainful of the movie or by acting like you know it is. I think one of the things that helps with Adam Driver's performance is when he's saying nonsense or he's doing things that doesn't make sense,
这就是我更欣赏他的地方，看完这部电影后，我对他的敬意增加了。嗯，我们在播客电影中经常看到的一点是，当你是一个出演了一部毫无意义或不好的电影的演员时。你永远不会因为公开蔑视这部电影或表现得好像你知道它很烂而赢得加分。我认为有助于亚当·德赖弗表演的一点是，当他在说废话或做一些毫无意义的事情时，
he is still acting as if the things that he's doing make sense and are rational and coherent. And I think you're right, he comes out of it. I mean, I feel like there's, most of the main performances come out pretty well. They're goofy and stuff but I'm just surprised like how he comes out like he there's a lesson in here with like watching him and maybe that's worth watching which is like even in life or in a movie or as a piece of art or
他仍然表现得好像他所做的事情是有意义、理性和连贯的。而且我觉得你是对的，他从中走出来了。我的意思是，我觉得大多数主要表演都表现得相当不错。它们很滑稽之类的，但我只是惊讶于他怎么能走出来，他在这里有一个教训，就像看着他，也许这值得一看，那就是即使在生活中，或在电影中，或作为一件艺术品，或
whatever just lean in and do the thing you will be cooler if you just do it rather than try to resist. Yeah well that's also like, from what I understand from hearing people talk about it, he had a much better sort of experience on the movie because he leaned into the working process of the movie. And I understand that if you don't want to lean into that, that's fine, because it sounds like this was not a good working experience for a lot of people.
无论什么，只要投入并去做那件事，如果你只是去做而不是试图抗拒，你会更酷。是的，这也是，据我从人们谈论它时了解到的，他在电影中有更好的工作体验，因为他投入到了电影的制作过程中。我明白如果你不想投入其中，那没关系，因为听起来这对很多人来说不是一次好的工作经历。
If you don't want to be told to do something different every single moment in the difference work, or suddenly kiss you when you don't like it. More harass, yeah, yeah. So I'm not necessarily making an argument to ignore that, but I am saying that he seemed to embrace, okay, as an artistic thing, I'm going to roll with this and be collaborative and really commit to it,
如果你不想在每一刻都被告知做不同的事情，或者突然在你不想的时候亲吻你。更多骚扰，是的，是的。所以我并不是一定要争论去忽视这一点，但我是在说，他似乎拥抱了这一点，好吧，作为一种艺术行为，我要顺其自然，进行合作并真正投入其中，
and that's probably part of why he does come out feeling like he... I mean, we also, I don't think we need to get into it, but I'm sure there was also an element of Francis Ford Coppola probably treating him better than he treated other people, you know, because he's the star that he identifies with in the movie, you know. True, true. And he loved 65. So he saw that and he was like, you were shooting dinosaurs. No, no, Francis,, you were shooting dinosaurs.
这可能就是他出来时感觉像他……的一部分原因。我的意思是，我们也不需要深入探讨，但我肯定弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉可能对他比对其他人更好，你知道，因为他是电影中他所认同的明星，你知道。真的，真的。而且他喜欢《65》。所以他看到了，他说，你在拍恐龙。不，不，弗朗西斯，你在拍恐龙。
No, no, Francis, those weren't real dinosaurs. He's like, I saw that movie you made where you got away from that comet that hit the earth with the dinosaurs. So I'm having a satellite hit the city. Let's see if you can get away from that one. And then Francis Gribble is watching his own movie. He's like, son of a bitch did it again.
不，不，弗朗西斯，那些不是真正的恐龙。他说，我看了你拍的那部电影，你从那颗带着恐龙撞击地球的彗星中逃脱了。所以我让一颗卫星撞击城市。让我们看看你能不能从那次撞击中逃脱。然后弗朗西斯·科波拉看着他自己的电影。他说，这个混蛋又做到了。
He got away from another thing falling out of the sky. Like. No. And Adam Driver's like, Francis, you made this movie. Like you knew what was going to happen. I don't think so. I don't think so. I don't know how you did it. And Adam Driver's like, Francis, you made this movie. You knew it was going to happen. I don't think so. I don't think so.
他又从另一个从天而降的东西中逃脱了。就像。不。亚当·德赖弗说，弗朗西斯，你拍了这部电影。就像你知道会发生什么一样。我不这么认为。我不这么认为。我不知道你是怎么做到的。亚当·德赖弗说，弗朗西斯，你拍了这部电影。你知道会发生什么。我不这么认为。我不这么认为。
I don't know how you did it. Doesn't seem like my movie. I mean, my movies are good. This one, I don't know. What if it was like Severance, where when he went to set, he had a different personality than when he left set. Probably. It'd be.
我不知道你是怎么做到的。看起来不像我的电影。我的意思是，我的电影很好。这一部，我不知道。如果它像《人生切割术》（Severance）那样，当他去片场时，他有一种与离开片场时不同的个性呢？可能吧。会是这样。
After the break, more from the Flomp House. Let's answer a couple of questions from listeners. This one is from Nilo Last Name Withheld. This is from FF Coppola. Or perhaps Nilo. I don't know. But they write, intergalactic greetings, floppers. I have a gigantic projector built in space capable of projecting a movie onto the moon. What should I show on it?
休息之后，更多来自“烂片屋”（Flop House）的内容。让我们回答几个听众的问题。这一条来自尼洛（Nilo），姓氏保密。这是来自FF·科波拉。或者可能是尼洛。我不知道。但他们写道，星际问候，烂片客们。我有一个巨大的投影仪建在太空中，能够把电影投射到月球上。我应该放什么电影？
And of course, you know, the first thing that comes to mind is from the earth to the moon. You want to see that moon man get, you know, a rocket in his eye. Yep. Yeah, everybody's gagging for it. Everyone wants that. They'll look up and be like, ugh. They want to see this big as... Finally, the real Moon's going to get the just-desert stuff the film Moon got.
当然，你知道，首先想到的是《月球旅行记》（From the Earth to the Moon）。你想看到那个月球人被，你知道，火箭射中眼睛。是的。每个人都渴望看到。每个人都想要那个。他们会抬头看，然后说，呃。他们想看到这个巨大的……终于，真正的月球将得到电影月球得到的应有报应。
Yeah, finally the stand-up-and-cheer moment of the year. But what else? A moonfall, maybe? I was going to say Akira for that scene when Tetsuo blows up part of the moon. I mean, so I'm going to think about this a little more practically. We don't have sound, right? Because it's just being projected. Yeah, Akira works perfect. So you have to tune your radio to a certain frequency.
是的，终于迎来了年度“起立欢呼”的时刻。但还有什么？《月球陨落》（Moonfall）？我本来想说《阿基拉》（Akira），因为铁雄炸毁月球一部分的那一幕。我的意思是，我要更实际地考虑这个问题。我们没有声音，对吧？因为它只是被投射出来。是的，《阿基拉》效果完美。所以你必须把收音机调到特定的频率。
Oh, maybe, yeah. I'm trying to think of something that would be kind of like that the visuals would pull all of humanity together as one shared family. Yeah. Once it's projected on the moon. One Week by Buster Keaton. Mm-hmm. I don't know.
哦，也许吧，是的。我正在尝试想一些视觉效果能把全人类团结成一个共同家庭的东西。是的。一旦投射到月球上。巴斯特·基顿（Buster Keaton）的《一周》（One Week）。嗯。我不知道。
Yeah, sure. Yeah. I mean, you're basically talking about the biggest movie in the park that you can imagine for the summertime. And so it's going to be like Toy Story. Yeah. I don't think it's going to work. Worst things you can go with than Toy Story. No, but it's going to be some Pixar movie that you can bring all the kids to.
是的，当然。我的意思是，你基本上是在谈论你能想象到的夏天公园里最大的电影。所以它会像《玩具总动员》（Toy Story）。是的。我不认为这行得通。比《玩具总动员》更糟糕的选择。不，但它会是一些你可以带所有孩子去看的皮克斯电影。
And then and that's it. Well, listen, I want to be some Pixar movie that you can bring all the kids to and then and that's it. Well, listen, I want to be family friendly because if my kids are out looking at the moon, I don't want them seeing something that they shouldn't see. Yeah. Different kind of movies. What shouldn't they see? It's on the list. I mean, I don't think they're ready for a Kira.
然后，就是这样。好吧，听着，我想成为家庭友好的，因为如果我的孩子们在外面看月球，我不希望他们看到他们不该看的东西。是的。不同类型的电影。他们不该看什么？它在名单上。我的意思是，我不认为他们准备好看《阿基拉》了。
Well, when are your kids going to be ready for a Kira? Daddy, daddy, why is Tetsuo expanding into a techno-organic mass? Why is he crushing Cowrie when he's trying to love her? One of these crimes of the future. So Dan, that's your vote is crimes of the future. Are you saying Roman? I saw Paris is burning and Lincoln Center outside and that was a lovely experience. So I could be one that you could do.
好吧，你的孩子们什么时候准备好看《阿基拉》？爸爸，爸爸，为什么铁雄正在膨胀成一团科技有机物质？为什么他在试图爱她时却在压碎香织？这些《未来罪行》（Crimes of the Future）之一。所以丹，你的投票是《未来罪行》。你是这个意思吗，罗曼？我在林肯中心外面看了《巴黎在燃烧》（Paris Is Burning），那是一次很棒的体验。所以我可以成为你可以做的一个。
I like it. This second and final letter is from Anne Marie who writes, Hey y'all. And this is a, this is clearly in response to our recent break into flop TV episode we had. I wanted to add- Tickets and season tickets available now for flop TV season two. I wanted to add an additional theory
我喜欢。这第二封也是最后一封信来自安妮·玛丽（Anne Marie），她写道，嘿，你们好。这显然是对我们最近“闯入烂片电视”（break into flop TV）那一集的回复。我想补充——“烂片电视”第二季的门票和季票现已发售。我想补充一个额外的理论
about how someone could dance on the ceiling. A few years ago, I played dancing on the ceiling for my then four year old niece, and she said it was her favorite song. I showed her the music video and she kept asking, how did he do that? And then posited that he had sticky stuff on the ceiling so he could stick to it like a bug.
关于一个人如何在天花板上跳舞。几年前，我为我当时四岁的侄女播放了《天花板上跳舞》（Dancing on the Ceiling），她说这是她最喜欢的歌。我给她看了音乐录影带，她一直问，他是怎么做到的？然后推测他在天花板上涂了粘性物质，这样他就能像虫子一样粘在上面。
So there's another- Yeah, yeah, that's how bugs stick to things. Alternative- That's a good theory. Well, it's not really, I don't think it's really how they stick to stuff. That's how it works in Inception too, right? Is Chrissy Nolan just smeared sticky stuff all over the ceiling
所以还有另一个——是的，是的，这就是虫子粘在东西上的方式。替代方案——那是个好理论。嗯，这并不是，我不认为这就是它们粘在东西上的方式。在《盗梦空间》（Inception）里也是这样工作的，对吧？克里斯·诺兰（Chrissy Nolan）只是在天花板上涂满了粘性物质，
and Joseph Gordon-Levitt bounced off of it? Yeah. So was there a question there, Dan? No, it was just sharing an idea? This is a charming tale of a child's imagination. Sort of like, you know, ET, I guess that's not an imagination, but it sparks imagination. Anyway. I mean, I don't know, E.T., I guess that's not an imagination, but it sparks imagination anyway.
然后约瑟夫·高登-莱维特（Joseph Gordon-Levitt）从上面弹开了？是的。所以那里有个问题吗，丹？不，只是分享一个想法？这是一个关于孩子想象力的迷人故事。有点像，你知道，《E.T.外星人》，我想那不是想象力，但它激发了想象力。总之。我的意思是，我不知道，《E.T.》，我想那不是想象力，但它激发了想象力。
I mean, I love old, old special effects are great. The greatest special effect of all time is Kermit riding a bike. It'll never be beaten. It'll be the greatest. Like that's, that's the thing that's wowed me the most for all my life. There's also a scene, a woman turns, goes from nice looking to evil looking in, in camera in a movie called The Octopus in a way that uses makeup that only shows up on certain colors of light,
我的意思是，我喜欢老电影，老特效很棒。有史以来最伟大的特效是科米蛙（Kermit）骑自行车。它永远不会被超越。它将是最伟大的。就像那是，那是我一生中最让我惊叹的事情。还有一个场景，一个女人在一部叫《章鱼》（The Octopus）的电影中，在镜头前从好看变得邪恶，使用了一种只在特定颜色的光线下才会显示的化妆，
and they had a gel there. And that effect, it's from a movie from the 30s, and the effect looks amazing. Yeah, I still think the best special effect is that scene where the guy falls over in the movie The Gate, and he turns into a bunch of little guys. That's pretty good.
他们那里有一个滤色片。那个效果，来自一部30年代的电影，效果看起来很棒。是的，我仍然认为最好的特效是《大门》（The Gate）里那个家伙摔倒，然后变成一堆小人的场景。那很不错。
Yeah, that's pretty amazing. And also there's the moment in Throne of Blood when Tashira Mufune gets an arrow to the neck. And I'm always like, did they really kill him? On that note of credulity, let's move on. Actually, Elliot, I just checked. Tashira Mufune's dead. Oh, no.
是的，那太神奇了。还有《蜘蛛巢城》（Throne of Blood）中三船敏郎（Toshiro Mifune）脖子中箭的那一刻。我总是想，他们真的杀了他吗？带着这种轻信，让我们继续。其实，埃利奥特（Elliot），我刚查了一下。三船敏郎死了。哦，不。
They did it. Officer, arrest Akira Kurosawa. We've resolved the cold case. Let us move on to our final segment, our final regular segment of the show, which is... Dan, I'm looking as you scan through your letterbox, I see Dicks the Musical on there. That scene with Nathan Lane spitting lunch meat on those puppets. Isn't that great? I appreciate the spirit of Dix the musical.
他们真的做了。警官，逮捕黑泽明（Akira Kurosawa）。我们解决了这桩悬案。让我们进入节目的最后一个环节，我们最后一个常规环节，那就是……丹，我看着你浏览你的Letterboxd，我看到了《迪克斯音乐剧》（Dicks: The Musical）。内森·连恩（Nathan Lane）把午餐肉吐在那些木偶身上的那一幕。那不是很棒吗？我欣赏《迪克斯音乐剧》的精神。
I didn't enjoy it as much as I think you did. So why are you recommending it, Dan? I'm not, this is, again, I haven't even introduced the segment, which is... I'm just looking over Dan's shoulders. We're recommending movies that we have seen of late or just like that might be a better use of your time than say Megalopolis, take Roman's advice, either stare at your loved one's face or watch one of these. Just stare at their face for the full runtime of Megalopolis, which is like two hours and
我没有像你那样享受它。那你为什么要推荐它，丹？我没有，这又是，我甚至还没介绍这个环节，那就是……我只是在看丹的肩膀。我们正在推荐我们最近看过的电影，或者可能比《大都会》更值得你花时间看的电影，听从罗曼的建议，要么盯着你爱人的脸看，要么看这些电影之一。只要盯着他们的脸看完整部《大都会》的时长，也就是大约两小时
18 minutes. They'll be like, what are you doing? Can you stop that? Is Megalopolis showing on my face? I recently just, I just rewatched Lost Highway highway which I hadn't seen since around the time it was new David Lynch's lost highway and You know because I'd seen it when it was new it kind of had never struck me like oh How much this is a dry run for Mulholland Drive?
18分钟。他们会说，你在做什么？你能停下来吗？《大都会》在我的脸上放映吗？我最近刚重看了《妖夜慌踪》（Lost Highway），我自从它刚出来的时候就没看过。大卫·林奇（David Lynch）的《妖夜慌踪》。你知道，因为我刚出来时看过它，它从来没有让我觉得，哦，这在多大程度上是《穆赫兰道》（Mulholland Drive）的预演？
Which is not to say it's not valuable in its own right, but it's like, oh, okay, you're revisiting so many of the themes, and I didn't even think about that. Of sort of, you know, Lynch's films, I think it's a bad idea to try and just decode them, but if you're gonna go down that road, there's a lot about sort of- Is that road Mulholland Drive?
这并不是说它本身没有价值，但就像，哦，好吧，你正在重温这么多主题，我甚至没想过这一点。关于，你知道，林奇的电影，我认为试图解码它们是个坏主意，但如果你要走那条路，有很多关于……那条路是《穆赫兰道》吗？
Yeah. Disassociation after sort of a horrible event, trying to make sense of your life through these like sort of fantasies. Lost Highway was his first trip down that lost highway to Mulholland Drive. And you're going to want to go down Lost Highway, you're going to take a turn onto Mulholland Drive. Yeah. And it's going to get you to the Inland Empire.
是的。在某种可怕事件后的解离，试图通过这些幻想来理解你的生活。《妖夜慌踪》是他第一次沿着那条“迷失的高速公路”前往《穆赫兰道》。你会想走《妖夜慌踪》，你会转弯进入《穆赫兰道》。是的。它会把你带到《内陆帝国》（Inland Empire）。
Yep. If you want to see Bill Pullman just wail on a saxophone as well, that's your best chance. I don't know. Some would say your only chance. There's not much to say about it. I mean, if you like Lynch and you haven't seen it, that's strange. If you haven't watched it, if you're not a Lynch person, maybe it haven't watched it if you're not a Lynch person. What if you're like a huge Robert Blake fan? Yeah, but not his movies, more his personal life.
是的。如果你想看比尔·普尔曼（Bill Pullman）吹萨克斯风，那也是你最好的机会。我不知道。有些人会说是你唯一的机会。没什么好说的。我的意思是，如果你喜欢林奇而且没看过，那很奇怪。如果你没看过，如果你不是林奇的粉丝，也许……如果你不是林奇的粉丝，没看过。如果你是罗伯特·布莱克（Robert Blake）的超级粉丝呢？是的，但不是他的电影，更多是他的个人生活。
Not his eyebrows. I love Robert Blake, I just hate when he has hair below his forehead. Is there a movie for me? Anyway. That's one of those movies, I feel like Lost Highway is the opposite of Megalopolis in that it is a movie that when it came out, I remember the reviews were like, what? They were scathing because it had a non-linear, not totally rational plot, but you watch it now and you're like, oh, now I know what Lynch does. I understand what he's doing. Honestly, the fact that film reviewers saw at the time and weren't like, oh, it's a David Lynch movie. I have to watch it through David Lynch glasses.
不是他的眉毛。我爱罗伯特·布莱克，我只是讨厌他额头下面有头发。有适合我的电影吗？总之。那是那种电影之一，我觉得《妖夜慌踪》和《大都会》相反，因为它是一部电影，当它出来时，我记得评论是，什么？它们非常尖刻，因为它有一个非线性的、不完全理性的情节，但你现在看它，你会说，哦，现在我知道林奇在做什么了。我明白他在做什么。老实说，影评人在当时看到它，却没有说，哦，这是一部大卫·林奇的电影。我必须戴着大卫·林奇的眼镜看它。
Yeah. I don't know if I ever told this story, but I remember seeing it like the very small independent theater in my hometown. And it was a late screening and we got out and I was driving my friends home. And I remembered, you know, driving up to a red light, the light turned green and then it turned red again.
是的。我不知道我是否讲过这个故事，但我记得在我的家乡一家很小的独立电影院看它。那是一场深夜放映，我们出来后，我开车送朋友回家。我记得，你知道，开车到一个红绿灯前，灯变绿了，然后又变红了。
And I had just sat there the whole time because my brain was processing what I just watched. Yeah, a lot. Let's go in the same order we did our judgements. Stuart, what do you have? Okay, I'm going to recommend a movie I saw a couple weeks back. I saw Anora, the new Sean Baker movie.
我整个时间都坐在那里，因为我的大脑正在处理我刚才看的东西。是的，很多。让我们按照我们评价的顺序来。斯图尔特，你有什么？好的，我要推荐一部我几周前看的电影。我看了《阿诺拉》（Anora），肖恩·贝克（Sean Baker）的新电影。
It's a, I guess, a offbeat comedy love story about a young sex worker who marries the son of an oligarch in Brighton Beach, Brooklyn. It's a very New York movie in that way. There's a scene where they fucking go to Tatiana's in Brighton Beach and I was like, whoa, I go there. And yeah, I mean, yeah, I'm like a Nora. It Yeah, I mean, I feel like it really captures the like rush and craziness of like love and hope. And also like hoping against the crushing power of capitalism and shittiness.
这是一部，我想，关于一个年轻性工作者嫁给布鲁克林布莱顿海滩一个寡头儿子的非主流喜剧爱情故事。从这个意义上说，这是一部非常纽约的电影。有一个场景，他们他妈的去了布莱顿海滩的塔蒂亚娜（Tatiana's），我当时想，哇，我去过那里。是的，我的意思是，是的，我像阿诺拉。它……我的意思是，我觉得它真正捕捉到了那种爱与希望的冲动和疯狂。还有，就像希望对抗资本主义和糟糕透顶的压迫力量。
And then of course, things start to come back to earth and things get a little bit rough. It's got an incredible central performance by Mikey Madison as the title character. Yeah, I think, I thought it was great. I love it. Yeah, check it out. I'm also going to recommend an offbeat comedy romance,
然后当然，事情开始回到现实，事情变得有点粗糙。它有一个令人难以置信的核心表演，由麦基·麦迪逊（Mikey Madison）饰演主角。是的，我想，我觉得它很棒。我喜欢它。是的，去看看吧。我也要推荐一部非主流喜剧浪漫片，
but not the same one. This is,'m also going to recommend an offbeat comedy romance, but not the same one. I'm going to recommend the movie You and Me from 1938. This is a movie directed by Fritz Lang, director of Metropolis, the movie I mentioned earlier, but it's a very different movie than Metropolis. Sylvia Sidney is a woman who works at a department store, and the department store makes a point of hiring ex-convicts to give them a second chance at life. And George Raft is one of those ex-convicts and they fall in love.
但不是同一部。这是……我也要推荐一部非主流喜剧浪漫片，但不是同一部。我要推荐1938年的电影《你和我》（You and Me）。这是一部由弗里茨·朗（Fritz Lang）执导的电影，他是《大都会》的导演，我之前提到的那部电影，但它是一部与《大都会》非常不同的电影。西尔维娅·西德尼（Sylvia Sidney）是一个在百货公司工作的女人，百货公司特意雇佣前罪犯，给他们第二次生命的机会。乔治·拉夫特（George Raft）是那些前罪犯之一，他们坠入爱河。
She doesn't want him to know she's also an ex-convict because when you're on parole, you're not allowed to fall in love and you're not allowed to get married. And so that she has to hide from him that she is also a convict and that the repercussions of that involve him getting back involved in crime.
她不想让他知道她也是个前罪犯，因为当你假释时，你不被允许坠入爱河，也不被允许结婚。所以她必须向他隐瞒她也是个罪犯，而这带来的后果包括他重新卷入犯罪。
And it's a surprisingly sweet movie for a movie about criminals directed by Fritz Lang. And it also has some musical numbers in it with some of the music written by Kurt Weill. So it's a like it's a it's a real strange movie. It's this kind of somewhat anti capitalist romance drama comedy crime movie with but with Sylvia Sidney and George Raft. But I really loved it. I really enjoyed it. It's the kind of movie that you could crank out in the 30s because they were making so many movies that sometimes one of these popped out
对于一部由弗里茨·朗执导的关于罪犯的电影来说，这是一部令人惊讶的甜蜜电影。它里面还有一些音乐片段，其中一些音乐是由库尔特·魏尔（Kurt Weill）创作的。所以它是一部非常奇怪的电影。这是一种某种程度上反资本主义的浪漫剧情喜剧犯罪电影，但有西尔维娅·西德尼和乔治·拉夫特。但我真的很喜欢它。我真的很享受。这是那种你在30年代就能拍出来的电影，因为他们拍了太多的电影，有时会冒出这样一部，
where it was like, this is kind of a stranger movie than it had any right to be. It could have been a pretty down-the-middle movie, but there's some great scenes in it. And, you know, Sylvia Sidney's been on my mind since there's that new Beetlejuice movie. She's not in the new one, but since she was in the old one. So that's you and me. Play Juno.
它就像，这是一部比它应有的更奇怪的电影。它本可以是一部非常平庸的电影，但里面有一些很棒的场景。而且，你知道，自从那部新的《阴间大法师》（Beetlejuice）电影以来，西尔维娅·西德尼一直在我脑海中。她没演新的那部，但因为她演了旧的那部。所以这就是《你和我》。播放朱诺（Juno）。
I have a hard time thinking of what to recommend, but I think the one I'd settle on is Hearts of Darkness of Filmmakers Apocalypse, which is the documentary Eleanor Coppola made of Francis Ford Coppola making Apocalypse, which is the documentary Eleanor Coppola made of Francis Ford Coppola making Apocalypse Now. One of the things that ends the movie, Megalopolis, is at the very end it says for Eleanor, which is sort of like this moment where I'm feeling like kind of seething for this thing.
我很难想到推荐什么，但我认为我最终决定的是《黑暗之心：电影制作人的启示录》（Hearts of Darkness: A Filmmaker's Apocalypse），这是埃莉诺·科波拉（Eleanor Coppola）拍摄的关于弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉制作《现代启示录》（Apocalypse Now）的纪录片。电影《大都会》结尾的一件事是，在最后它写着“献给埃莉诺”，这就像是我对这件事感到有点沸腾的时刻。
And then there's a sweet moment of their long term relationship and how she was such a gifted filmmaker as evidenced by this piece that did like make me think, okay, he did what he wanted to, it's all okay. And that was a nice sort of like homage to her, but she was an extremely good documentary filmmaker. It made me appreciate Apocalypse Now so much more. It gave you so much insight into making a movie. It's just like has so much drama.
然后是他们长期关系中甜蜜的一刻，以及她是如何成为一位如此有天赋的电影制作人，正如这部作品所证明的那样，这确实让我觉得，好吧，他做了他想做的事，一切都好。那是一种对她很好的致敬，但她是一位非常出色的纪录片制作人。它让我更加欣赏《现代启示录》。它让你对制作电影有了很多深入的了解。它只是有太多的戏剧性。
It's so fascinating. I really love Hearts of Darkness. I saw it as a kid. I'm not a kid. I guess I was pretty soon after it came out. I guess I was 15 or 16. And Hearts of Darkness, not Apocalypse Now. I had not seen Apocalypse Now.
太迷人了。我真的很喜欢《黑暗之心》。我小时候看过。我不是个孩子。我想我在它出来后不久就看了。我想我当时15或16岁。是《黑暗之心》，不是《现代启示录》。我还没看过《现代启示录》。
I caught this like on HBO or something and then I saw it afterward. I'd kind of heard about Apocalypse Now and it just gave me the blueprint for appreciating another sort of like good mess of a movie. You know, that's a, I think that's a good mess of Apocalypse Now in a lot of ways. But I love this. It's one of the reasons why I love documentaries. I think it's just expertly and beautifully made. Heart's a-
我在HBO之类的频道上看到了这个，然后我之后才看了电影。我听说过《现代启示录》，它只是给了我欣赏另一部“好坏参半”电影的蓝图。你知道，那是一个，我认为那是《现代启示录》在很多方面的一个好坏参半的例子。但我喜欢这个。这是我喜欢纪录片的原因之一。我认为它制作得非常专业和精美。黑暗之心——
I think I also saw it before I saw Apocalypse Now. I saw it with my college girlfriend. We were at her house in Cleveland and we went to, it was like young film buffs. And we're like, what artie thing can we get? We'll get this. I know it's a good documentary. And it is a testament to it,
我想我也在看《现代启示录》之前看了它。我和我的大学女友一起看的。我们在克利夫兰她家，我们去了，就像年轻的电影迷。我们想，我们可以得到什么艺术的东西？我们要这个。我知道这是一部好纪录片。它是它的证明，
like even without having seen the movie, like this is fascinating in its own right and then gets richer once you've seen the film or like most people you probably see Apocalypse Now first and then catch up. I mean, it's weird. I mean, I think people take things in a lot differently now and like you never know, but I think this movie is great.
即使没看过那部电影，这本身就很迷人，而且一旦你看过那部电影，它就会变得更丰富，或者像大多数人一样，你可能先看《现代启示录》，然后补看这个。我的意思是，这很奇怪。我的意思是，我认为人们现在接受事物的方式大不相同，你永远不知道，但我认为这部电影很棒。
I think it's actually better than Apocalypse Now. But that's my own flavor of, that to me is like not defensible, that's just taste. You know, it's- That's just a personal choice. Dan, there are people who saw Spaceballs before Star Wars. People watch things in all sorts of crazy orders, you know. Yeah.
我认为它实际上比《现代启示录》更好。但那是我的个人口味，对我来说那是不值得辩护的，那只是品味。你知道，这是——那只是个人选择。丹，有些人先看了《太空炮弹》（Spaceballs）才看《星球大战》。人们以各种疯狂的顺序看东西，你知道。是的。
These days. I thought you were about to mention a documentary about the making of Spaceballs. That would be fascinating. The people who see May the Schwartz be with you in a filmmaker's journey. That's not what Balls of Fury was? Yeah. How'd they rig up that bit where Rick Moranis goes flying through the...
这些天。我以为你要提到一部关于《太空炮弹》制作的纪录片。那会很迷人。那些看《愿原力与你同在》（May the Schwartz be with you）的电影制作人旅程的人。那不是《愤怒的球》（Balls of Fury）吗？是的。他们是怎么操纵里克·莫拉尼斯（Rick Moranis）飞过……的那一幕的？
Sounds like a documentary to find out. Was that real? Did they kill Rick Moranis? Did they kill Rick Moranis in that moment? All right. Well, we should wrap this up with a big thank you. Real? Did they kill Frank Moranis? Did they kill Frank Moranis in that moment? All right. Well, we should wrap this up with a big thank you. No, I want to see.
听起来像是一部纪录片要找出的。那是真的吗？他们杀了里克·莫拉尼斯吗？他们在那一刻杀了里克·莫拉尼斯吗？好吧。嗯，我们应该用一声大大的谢谢来结束这一切。真的吗？他们杀了弗兰克·莫拉尼斯吗？他们在那一刻杀了弗兰克·莫拉尼斯吗？好吧。嗯，我们应该用一声大大的谢谢来结束这一切。不，我想看。
No, wait. Sorry, I want to see a comedy sketch and a show where they're like, okay, they're trying to lead actor on a movie set and they're like, we saved this last stunt to the end of the shooting because you're going to die when you do it. The only way to get the shot is to kill you while you do it. Oh, okay. That's why we shot all your scenes ahead of it. So I don't know if that's a good idea.
不，等等。抱歉，我想看一个喜剧小品和一个节目，他们就像，好吧，他们正在尝试电影片场的男主角，他们就像，我们把这个最后的特技留到拍摄结束，因为你做的时候会死。得到镜头的唯一方法是在你做的时候杀了你。哦，好吧。这就是为什么我们提前拍了你所有的场景。所以我不知道这是否是个好主意。
No, it's okay. We shot the rest of the movie already. We shot it already, we're done. We're wrapped on that. So this is your last thing you have to do. We'll be covered. Before we say goodbye, I want to just say thank you to Roman for being on this episode. We all know how busy you are, and so we're always charmed
不，没关系。我们已经拍完了电影的其余部分。我们已经拍完了，我们完成了。我们拍完了。所以这是你必须做的最后一件事。我们会覆盖的。在我们说再见之前，我只想对罗曼参加这一集表示感谢。我们都知道你有多忙，所以我们总是很着迷
when you make time for our shenanigans. It's a long time fan and supporter. I'm so happy to be here. It makes me very, very happy. What are you going to say? If you want more shenanigans like this, just tune into the 99% invisible breakdown, The Power Broker.
当你为我们的恶作剧腾出时间时。作为长期的粉丝和支持者。我很高兴来到这里。这让我非常非常高兴。你要说什么？如果你想要更多这样的恶作剧，只需收听《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）的拆解，《权力掮客》（The Power Broker）。
Exactly the same. It's exactly like this show. It's just like it. Yeah. Just cutting it up. Before we go, thank you to our producer, Alex Smith. He goes by the name Howell Doddy on the internet. He does music.
完全一样。就像这个节目一样。就是这样。没错。只是把它剪辑一下。在结束之前，感谢我们的制作人亚历克斯·史密斯。他在网上的名字叫豪威尔·多迪。他负责音乐制作。
He does Twitch streams, does a lot of stuff. Look him up. Thank you to our network, Maximum Fun. If you go to MaximumFun.org, there are a lot of great other podcasts you can listen to about culture, about comedy. You'll find something you like. But that's it for this episode for the Flophouse. I've been Dan McCoy. I'm Stuart Wellington.
他还会做Twitch直播，做了很多事情。去搜搜他吧。感谢我们的网络平台Maximum Fun。如果你访问MaximumFun.org，那里有很多关于文化和喜剧的精彩播客可以收听。你一定会找到喜欢的。但本期《Flophouse》节目就到这里了。我是丹·麦考伊。我是斯图尔特·惠灵顿。
I'm Elliot Kalin. I'm Roman Mars. I'm going to take that again. I'm Roman Mars. Like that. That's it. What a professional. Bye! Bye! Professionalism undone.
我是埃利奥特·卡林。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我要重来一次。我是罗曼·马尔斯。就像那样。就这样。真是专业。再见！再见！专业精神荡然无存。
Roman's like, let me make sure I say that the right way. And then Stuart's like, eww! Do it? On this episode we discuss Megalopolis. Do you want me to have one? On this episode we discuss Megalopolis. Do you want me to have one? Do you want me to do one? Stuart, you leaned in like you had one.
罗曼心想，让我确保我没说错。然后斯图尔特说，呃！要我来吗？在本期节目中，我们讨论了《大都会》。你想要我来一个吗？在本期节目中，我们讨论了《大都会》。你想要我来一个吗？你想要我做一个吗？斯图尔特，你刚才凑过来好像你要来一个似的。
I didn't say anything. We're embarrassing ourselves in front of Roman. No, no, no. Roman knows we're cool. This is the whole experience. You can listen and subscribe to the Flophouse wherever you get your podcasts. And after all that, if you still somehow want to watch Megalopolis, it's now available on VOD. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我什么都没说。我们在罗曼面前丢脸了。不，不，不。罗曼知道我们很酷。这就是完整的体验。你可以在任何获取播客的地方收听并订阅《Flophouse》。经历了这一切之后，如果你仍然想看《大都会》，它现在可以在视频点播平台上观看了。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。